step number one
have a goal make it specific make sure
you know the rules of the game you're
playing make sure you know what a win
looks like in fact that may be the most
important question that you could ask
yourself the most pointed thing that you
can determine in your life
is to know what does it look like to win
once you know what it looks like to win
then you can work backwards then you can
figure out what you need to do to score
then you can figure out the skills that
you're going to need in order to get
great in order to go out and dominate in
order to be better than anyone that has
ever come before you but to do that
you've got to know
what your goal is
and once you have that as dale carnegie
said if you want to conquer fear don't
sit home and think about it go out and
get busy so now you have your goal
now you're telling people what you're
going to do now you're telling yourself
who you're going to become you're
building something up inside of you but
are you actually taking the action are
you actually getting out and doing
something about it
and it is terrifying to me how people
can pacify themselves with a sense of
accomplishment simply
by having a goal simply by telling
people that they're going to do
something simply by fantasizing about
what they're going to accomplish and let
me tell you right now the thing that
separates the people who dream from the
people who execute is a willingness to
act and at the end of the day nothing is
going to stop you not fear not inability
not inadequacy the only thing that will
stop you is failing to start
failing to start as your mortal enemy
you've got to find a way to get yourself
going you've got to find a way to take
that desire that interest in you and
turn it into a raging inferno something
that's going to get you moving and going
ahead that will trample everything in
its path once you're able to do that
nothing and i mean nothing will be able
to stop it
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only tom bilyeu
enjoy
perfectionism isn't
going to be the thing that serves you
what you want to do is focus on what
goal are you trying to attain and then
what's it going to take to get to that
goal 99 times out of 100 when you're
doing something let's say
at 80 perfect you get the result you get
the vast majority of the accolades or
the success metrics all of it can be got
without having to go all the way to that
last 20 and that last 20 is when you can
drive yourself absolutely insane so you
want to be really thoughtful about what
standard you're holding yourself to
because if all you're thinking is man
it's all the way or it is nothing
then what you have to admit is your goal
is perfection your goal isn't the thing
you're trying to accomplish right the
goal isn't to be a better parent or a
better spouse or better at your job the
goal as you are behaving
is perfection
now if when you say yes my goal is
perfection it's not the thing that i'm
doing it's it is being perfect so if i'm
going to brush my teeth i'm going to
brush my teeth perfectly
wonderful then at least you're being
honest and just know that by trying to
be that perfect you're going to far
narrow the scope of things that you can
do in a way that you wouldn't have to at
least not as much if you were say i'm
just after this goal by this date and i
may have to win ugly but i'm going to
get there
now that attitude gives you a lot more
freedom you can get in there you can
throw punches you can get muddy but as
long as you get to the end and you get
across the line and you get that victory
and that was what it was about then
things get a lot more interesting a
you're not going to be paralyzed by
perfectionism b you're valuing yourself
for achieving that thing going through
it fighting through the mud crawling
making mistakes all of that but you got
there in the end and then the big thing
in all of this is priority order and
this is where people really struggle you
have to be willing to put things in
order now this is where people struggle
because they feel a tremendous sense of
guilt that they have to do all of those
things as their number one priority
let me break that for you you cannot
have multiple number one priorities you
can't do it so i'll give you my life how
i go
my marriage is my number one priority my
business is number two and my family is
number three
that's the reality now i'm sure as my
family members it's not lovely to think
that you're in third place but my thing
is i'm trying to spend when i spend time
with them i'm spending quality time i am
focused on them i am 100 there not
trying to be perfect but i'm completely
engaged and by being completely engaged
they don't feel like they're in position
three because i've allocated that time
to be with them and i'm not trying to
work at the same time that i'm with them
when i'm with them
i'm with them and that's that but in
terms of making sure that things are
done in order
they're in that order so if cleaning
house is really important to you but
it's your fourth priority
then it's going to suffer and then the
question becomes why would you beat
yourself up for doing things in the
right order so you know that there is a
finite amount of time you know that if
these are the five things you want to
accomplish you only have 100 of your
time you're going to allocate a certain
percentage of your time to each of those
then what you're saying is this will get
the results that the percentage of time
that i've allocated to it allows it to
get
and just being really comfortable so i
don't beat myself up over that because i
know it's physics i am up against
physics i cannot slow time down so the
reality is that i'm only going to be
able to get so much done now of course
i can work to become more efficient and
all of that stuff and i do but at the
end of the day i realize that either
holding myself to this ridiculously high
expectation of perfectionism actually
reduces the number of things that i can
get done because that final twenty
percent ends up taking more time and
energy than the eighty percent that got
the result anyway
so
looping around that
instead of saying cool i'm going to get
there i might have to win ugly but i'm
going to get there and then putting
things in order so that i know yep the
thing at the bottom belongs at the
bottom for a reason and it is not going
to get the time and attention that the
other things are going to get
because that's how ordering things works
so you have to be fearless when it comes
to putting things in order but oddly
enough really really a lot of people get
tripped up with that don't let that be
you
own it
own what matters to you
in order
write it down and stick to it
if you do that
and then you don't need every little
thing to be perfect you can make some
crazy progress in the things that matter
most other things will fall by the
wayside it is what it is right now we're
all going to make a promise to ourselves
you can do it silently we want to have
everybody shouting it out but you're
going to make a promise to yourself
right now because if if you follow
through with what we're about to say
everything will be different if you fail
to do this you'll come back a year from
now and you're going to write the same
on the wall i promise because this is
the part that you have to break out of
make yourself a promise right now that
you will
disengage
your sense of self your sense of self
worth
from achievement
and you're gonna marry that
to pursuit once you are
wholly focused on sincere
pursuit
everything changes when you're focused
on outcome when you're saying to
yourself i want to get rich i want to
win the academy award ah those are my
dreams it's an end state right it
doesn't work like here's one of those
things things become trite because
they're so true so please for the love
of god don't make people repeat the most
obvious ever like money can't buy
happiness
okay money can't buy happiness it can
buy a lot of cool
it bought me a really nice house
in fact baby show the photo
yeah
we actually own part of that jet company
i'm not joking how crazy is that we know
the ceo there was one time where i was
trying to get on the flight they were
giving me i can't remember why and i
called the ceo up and i was like yo you
need to talk to your gate agent
like that's money
money is better than you think it is
more powerful than you think but it is
not at all what you've been told
money solves money problems and that's
awesome and there's a lot of cool stuff
that you can do with money there's no
joke so we run impact theory out of our
house our house is like 10 000 square
feet
swimming pool balconies all that crazy
one of our rooms is actually called like
actually when we bought the house they
called it this it's called the great
room
and that thing is big
i'm not joking we once played um
nerf with nerf guns we did like a whole
hide and seek capture the flag thing in
the house
it was crazy
so money does really extraordinary
things people will chase money forever
because money actually has utility so i
am not the guy that's saying oh money
doesn't matter or money's not a thing or
money's not worth a pursuit what i am
saying though money really can't buy
happiness the very thing you're pursuing
in your life is very simple it is
fulfillment that's it now i sum up
fulfillment very simply how do you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
do you feel good do you feel like you're
making the most of your life are you
tapping into what the greeks call techne
are you working your ass off
and that's a key component is it hard
are you working your ass off
sad but true are you working your ass
off for a set of skills
this is oh you this is the angry face
this this is this is about tapping into
rage we talked about that elizabeth not
at rage yet
we'll get there
but there we go
so
you really have to
work hard
for a set of skills
that matter to you
now the skills have to matter
that's a key part of the equation
once the skills matter to you
and they allow you to serve not only
yourself but other people and then you
actually go and serve those people it
becomes this really potent cocktail of
neurochemistry but i want to make sure
that everybody understands the game that
you're playing is a game of
neurochemistry right in the last year at
least two billionaires committed suicide
that's heartbreaking when anybody
commits suicide but when billionaires
start committing suicide like if the
answer is not just self-evident beyond
all imagining that money is not going to
solve the problems that exist between
your ears like there's there's nothing
more anyone can tell you a fool never
learns
a smart man learns from his mistakes a
wise man learns from the mistakes of
others on this one i'm begging you be
wise i'm not telling you not to chase
money i'm just saying it's not going to
feed you emotionally the way you think
it is so you've got to completely
divorce yourself from this notion of
outcome and become completely obsessed
with the idea of sincere pursuit
now why sincere pursuit
the reason to tie your
sense of self your self-esteem your
pride your ego your identity all of that
the reason to tie that to sincere
pursuit is it's the only part you can
control
i cannot promise you that you'll ever be
successful
you
cannot promise you
that you will be successful
but you can
promise
and know
if you actually did it
to show up every day and really pursue
it
you control your mindset
you control how you feel about yourself
nobody can actually get you to feel some
kind of way about yourself
you allow that right that's like the
cheesiest self-help you're ever going to
hear but it got cheesy because it's so
true so people repeated it a lot
and if you lose sight of that if you
lose sight of what you allow yourself to
think is going to control you at a
neurochemical level
and at the neurochemical level that's
going to influence then again how you
feel and how you think and then you get
into this death spiral where you're
thinking negative you believe in the
negative which makes you feel badly
about yourself and then you get stuck in
that you can't get out and you see a lot
of that on the hopes and fears
people are afraid they're never going to
be able to break free people in this
room that took the time to write it down
that they were never going to get out of
that negative loop
and that negative loop is really real
but here's the thing the negative loop
is based in biology
and once you begin to understand what
the biology is exactly then you can
begin to take control of your life and
step one in the biological train is to
break
the tie that you have
between
outcome
and worth
once you begin to break that down then
you can step naked in raw and say all
right this is just practice
and once you're in that mode of
practicing you're in skill acquisition
mode
and the name of the game is skill
acquisition like it really is sort of
that dull and boring it's just about
getting so good at something that you
can't be denied
and that's one of those things like i'm
going to say that phrase so much that i
worry that's going to become trite but
that is one of the most
awe-inspiring notions on the planet
the thought that you could become so
good at something
that you leave people in awe
and when you can leave people in awe
you can do just about anything you want
with your life
this is one of those things like people
really understood what i'm talking about
right now this one fact would change
their life forever you don't get skills
because it looks good on the resume
you get skills because it lets you do
the thing you want to do
so let's uh let's use sports as an
example it's just all too easy not to
use it so cristiano ronaldo in the grips
of poverty realizes that playing soccer
is a way out for him and so he goes and
gets the skills why because if he can
win on the soccer field then he can
actually elevate his family out of
poverty like when you see that trail it
goes back to the nietzsche quote if you
have a why you can survive almost any
how so
how am i going to get there the the
amount of work that cristiano ronaldo
has put in to become
one of the greatest if not the greatest
the greatest football player of all time
is it's inhuman anybody else would look
at and say nope not willing to do that
and fair enough but it was somebody who
said if i gain these skills it will let
me
dribble around people
score when other people can't score
galvanize a team around me leverage it
to be wanted by teams to turn into
financial resources to make me famous so
that i can get brand deals and things
like that all the things that he would
need to do to pull himself out of
poverty like this stuff isn't an
accident it's about skill acquisition so
there's another kid that had the same
dream i'm gonna use soccer to get me out
of poverty and did nothing about it
therefore did not have the skills
therefore could not elevate their family
out of poverty and looks at it like well
this is all circumstance it's not
circumstance it's cause and effect it's
how much energy do you put into actually
gaining the skills and did you gain them
or did you just put in the energy and
the effort thinking that should be
enough to gain it but you didn't
actually gain them so this is what it's
it's like the gift i want everybody to
receive is you can get good at anything
you set your mind to
but do you actually set your mind to it
do you have that inhuman level of
follow-through do you keep pushing and
fighting long after it stopped being fun
deep into boredom because you have a why
you know why you're doing what you're
doing and you're just driving towards
that and when you have that you can
accomplish this extraordinary stuff but
i really think people now are doing it
for the gram you're doing it for the
gram you want to go to that thing and do
it because it's like oh this is going to
look good on my gram and look i've done
that a hundred times i get it but at the
core of my existence is not that at the
core of my existence is i'm going to in
the amount of time that i have i'm going
to be acquiring skills i want to talk
about jocko willing's idea of no matter
what life throws at you the reaction is
good
i lost my job good my woman left me for
no reason good people took money from me
good all of it good once you
flip that switch in your mind like even
now that gave me the chills just
thinking how powerful
the reaction to the world's most
negative news
to say good yeah good
now you have to come up with a reason
why it's good
and
the reason that it's good is because you
know
that the only way to think about failure
quote unquote failure is like ai
artificial intelligence okay an ai
it's not
called failure it's called a sample okay
you try something so if you've ever seen
the video of ai learning to play the
video game breakthrough the old atari
game it is hilarious you see this paddle
squiggling around like crazy the
obviously the ai has no idea what it's
supposed to do so all it's programmed to
do is get a high score but it doesn't
know what gives it a score it doesn't
know am i supposed to move the paddle i
suppose hit the ball is the ball
supposed to you know break through the
blocks at the top and so it just like
does these random ass movements and then
finally it'll hit the ball and then
finally the ball breaks a brick and then
finally it finds the most efficient path
to break all of it now let me tell you
in my 20s i don't know about you but in
my 20s i was a mess in my early 20s i
was so
lost
frustrated
afraid
insecure
overwhelmed
paralyzed i mean it was
it was a dark period in my life
that's the nature of your 20s now in my
20s as old as this is going to make me
sound in my 20s the internet barely
existed so
we certainly didn't have youtube there
wasn't people putting out content that
would allow me to recontextualize my
world the fact that you already know the
quote that success is going from failure
to failure to failure without a loss of
enthusiasm you are so much farther ahead
than where i was
now i'm going to use an analogy
of love if i may
one of the things i find most
interesting about love is that
in love
you are opening yourself up to being far
more easily hurt
when you are in love it's a very
vulnerable state you have opened
yourself to somebody you've given
yourself over in a way to that person
and now you are far more easily hurt
they know your insecurities they
could weaponize them against you
and when heartbreak comes along
it's very tempting to turtle up
and to protect yourself
but then you're closed off from the
things that make love valuable in the
first place the very thing that makes
love worthwhile is being able to be open
like that to somebody to be vulnerable
to somebody
and the thing that makes love so
extraordinary
is that even when you get hurt
the people that can open themselves up
again and approach somebody
without the baggage of previous
relationships are the ones that end up
finding that
beautiful relationship that ends up
being worth the vulnerability and worth
the sacrifice
and
speaking from experience ends up being
the single greatest thing in your life
now if you learned nothing from the
heartbreak
i understand why it's scary to go into
the next thing
but the idea here the very way that we
bounce back from failure is by
looking exclusively
at what we can do differently
and when you look exclusively i'm not
saying other people didn't do something
that maybe it's
maybe any rational person would say it's
all their fault maybe the list of things
you gave us is literally you were just
the world's unluckiest human being
but the reason that we're going to say
good
the reason that we're going to look at
this like ai and samples the reason
we're going to remind ourselves that
success is going from failure to failure
to failure without a loss of enthusiasm
the reason that we're going to think of
that love analogy and be willing to open
ourselves back up
is because we're going to figure out
what we could have done differently
we're going to see what can i improve in
my skill set what did this catastrophe
reveal
about my strategy
and whenever a strategy yields a result
different than the desired result then
you know the strategy is by definition
wrong
and i want you to own that doesn't mean
you're a bad person okay but it does
mean that your strategy wasn't working
go back to ai right it's wiggling around
it finally realizes oh i need to hit the
ball okay cool so now i'm going to track
the movement of the ball and i'm going
to adjust my paddle to be there okay
cool i got it oh i actually see that
hitting it on the sides is far more
advantageous than hitting it in the
middle because once i clear a path on
the side then the ball can bounce around
on the top and destroy bricks far faster
than any other strategy
okay amazing but you had to first have
the reaction that that failure was good
good because it revealed the flaw in my
strategy and because i'm playing the
long-term game i'm going to open myself
back up again i'm going to allow myself
to be vulnerable again i'm going to
let the wound hurt as much as it needs
to for me to learn the lesson
no more not going to beat myself up over
it i'm not going to end up in a death
spiral of shame
but i am going to
recognize that i could do something
different the next time and get a
different result
that
to run the same strategy and expect the
result to change is as einstein said the
definition of insanity
so
that's what you have to do here you have
to recognize
that
this thing that you consider the worst
thing that ever happened to you with the
change of framing is actually the best
thing that ever happened to you and if
you change the question that you ask
about this and say how did this help me
what did i learn from this or what could
i learn from this
and how can this improve my strategy
moving forward then all of a sudden the
frame of reference changes the emotion
the way you feel about it the dark
energy that's around it begins to change
because you're stoked right this is good
all right i'm going to learn something
from this and it's going to be xyz and
maybe you only get incrementally better
and you try again and maybe you fail
again and you get incrementally better
and all of a sudden if your life is
anything like mine your 20s were getting
kicked in the face over and over and
over be getting a little bit better at
blocking a little bit better at avoiding
and then finally in your 30s you begin
to find your footing and then you turn
into beast mode late 30s early 40s and
now
you feel like you can really
move the world
it's exactly what it feels like when you
understand how your own mind works how
the minds of others work and just sort
of the nature of the world
it's really incredible but the only way
to get there is to flounder around
to make horrendous mistakes and say good
if something is really high value really
important the most important thing you
could be dealing with then you're gonna
do
everything you can do to move that ball
forward now inevitably no matter what it
is there will be times where you will
get to the point where
you need a break or there's nothing more
that you can do whatever
and so you're going to do everything
that you can do to push that ball
forward and then once you need to move
on for whatever reason
then or you're waiting for something
then you go and focus on the smaller
things but don't be afraid to say this
is my number one priority and so other
things are going to get less attention
so one thing i always tell people at
impact theory is
doing less
is always an option
what's not an option is hating your life
okay so we're not gonna do things that
allow us to hate our life so if i know
hey i've got a health issue i have to go
really ham but i also have all this
nicknacky bull that i have to deal with
i'm gonna take care of my health first
and foremost i'm gonna cut out things
that don't have
you know anything to do with that
because they are less important to me
and we went through this with lisa and
that meant that she was doing less at
work um you know if you have to take
paid time off or whatever do it if you
have to take unpaid
time off do it if you have to scale your
lifestyle back to make sure that you can
take unpaid time off do it there are a
thousand ways but when something is
truly the most important thing then you
need to address it as such
now what i find is everybody tries to
have these dueling competing number ones
they think that they're supposed to be
doing all of these things at the same
time
i'm just here to tell you that's not how
it works so you have to put things in
rank order there is no such thing as a
dual number one priority
okay there is number one there is number
two three four five six so on and so
forth okay so line them up do them in
that order and you have to be relentless
about it and you have to accept that not
everything is going to get done as well
as you want to get it done but it should
get done in priority order
i find people have a really hard time
with that that one to me is a bit weird
if your priorities are listed in order
of the things that are important to you
why would you do them in any other way
unless you're lying to yourself about
what's actually important to you
so if what's really important to you is
what your parents think about you well
then you might start making stupid
decisions because you're not being
honest that what you really want is to
please your parents now once you start
being honest
about what your priorities are like for
instance let's say you have a health
issue and you have kids and the reality
is that your kids are your number one
priority and your health is number two
now what do you do
you've got a choice you either have to
de-prioritize your children which is
going to be hard for some people or your
spouse or your job or whatever
but be honest and if you're not prepared
to de-prioritize your kids then you have
to own that and accept the consequences
namely depending on what your health
issue is you may die younger than you
otherwise would because you're not
addressing it
this is where we got to be honest we
have to say what's really going on we've
got to say what our priorities really
are and when we stop bullying ourselves
about what our priorities are then we
can execute in priority order and then
everything in life gets clear and simple
doesn't get easy
but it gets clear and it gets simple
do it to it as my mom would say
you're never going to get rid of the
fear of following your passion let's
start with that
as you said there is no such thing as
arriving in life and this is one of the
main ideas that i want people to really
grapple with as you think about how to
live your life well
is that there is no success big enough
that you can stand in that success
and that it will last forever really
this is a game of neurochemistry this is
how you feel this is what stresses you
out this is what do you love this is an
ever-changing
roller coaster of
emotions and so understanding that you
could fail
at a job that you hate i think this was
jim carrey's uh advice to his father
that you could fail at a job that you
hate so you might as well at least try
the one that you're going to love now
that doesn't mean that we just
throw caution to the wind and we're
going to get more into that with some of
the subsequent questions but recognizing
that
you will
never reach a destination the only
destination in life is death and that is
not a worthy aim you shouldn't be
thinking about that or focusing on that
or thinking uh in terms of you know i
just need to get to 95 or 150 or
whatever age you're aiming at this
really is a question about how you want
to feel every day and once you
understand that that there are things
that make you feel alive those things
you're passionate about those things
that give you more energy than they take
and then there are things that take more
energy than they give and so you want to
be very careful to structure your life
in a way that you're doing something
that gives you more energy than it takes
okay so we know that we're never going
to arrive because we know that we're
never going to arrive we understand that
this is really just a game of emotional
management because we know that this is
a game of emotional management then what
we're asking is what is this thing that
gives us passion is it giving us the
neurochemistry that we want or
is the thing that we're passionate about
so high risk that even though it would
be fun in the abstract once i really
commit to that and make it my job it
stops having that same sense of giving
me energy and that's the tension this is
where people end up not being able to
make a decision because they have not
yet figured out how to optimize their
life in such a way that they can pursue
that thing that they're passionate about
without
that sense of joy and
excitement and that incredible thrill of
getting better at something that you
love
doing and that even when it's hard it's
giving you that energy
because people can get lost in that they
get in there they think this is going to
be amazing that passion turns into a job
and then they lose the enthusiasm or
there's so much stress and pressure
around having to be successful at that
passion because you no longer have the
safety net of a job or whatever the case
may be
they don't recognize that
just pursuing something that's your
passion on paper isn't necessarily going
to solve that problem
that the problem fundamentally is that
life is an ever-changing rollercoaster
of emotion and the name of the game is
to
manage those emotions well okay so how
do we set it up if we have a passion and
we want to follow that how do we do it
well
so we know that we're never going to get
rid of the fear until we have
predictability and
um stability in terms of the financial
things that we need and i would say we
want to take care of that we want to
make sure
that we have as much safety and security
on the financial side as we can to give
us the room to pursue the things we're
passionate about now the fastest way to
do that is to cut your expenses to the
quick if you don't have an expensive
lifestyle this becomes a whole lot
easier and one of the mistakes that
people make is they're living a
lifestyle that's beyond their means and
so they have to keep making this massive
monthly nut and so it becomes very
stressful to pursue that thing that they
love okay so we're either going to
recognize that we have to reduce our
expenses so that we don't have to worry
so much about money or if we already
have a job that pays well we have to
pursue our passion in nights and
weekends fashion such that we can build
that financial stability so that we can
then progress
okay so getting that stability there i
think is really important the people
that have the strongest home life take
the biggest risks and oftentimes
pursuing that passion is going to be a
risk so instead of trying to eliminate
the fear we're going to structure our
life in such a way that the things that
trigger the fear aren't
as high risk okay that's a big part of
this then we want to make sure that
we're structuring our passion in such a
way that it doesn't end up robbing us of
the joy so we want to experiment with
what our passion
looks like as a financial endeavor and i
think that's a very important experiment
to run again nights and weekends without
making any major life choices is going
to be
very important now if we're in a
situation where the odds are stacked
against you this is where the first two
things we just walked through become
incredibly important you want to make
sure that you've got your finances taken
care of so that if this fails that it
doesn't drag you down that will make it
not fun and again there's no
accomplishment so great that you can
stand in that forever so even if you
were to be successful you still have to
deal with the emotional management
so do not put yourself in this hyper
stressful situation
where it's you're always living for the
future because the success is not
guaranteed but the struggle is
so the key is to struggle well
once you accept
that the thing that separates you from
the rest of the animal kingdom
is an unimaginable ability to become
you have an
unimaginable ability to become something
in 2014 private companies averaged eight
percent annual growth
after i went into my partners and i said
i quit
and i'm gonna go do something that makes
me feel alive they were totally shocked
and i got all the way to my house and i
was on the phone with my wife i did it i
had been unhappy for so long
and i said i did it i told him i quit i
gave back the equity here i am and i'm
pulling into the driveway at my house
and my phone rings
and it's my partners
they say come out to dinner with us
out of respect and love i went out to
dinner with them
and they said the now famous words
we could do this without you
but we don't want to
and that gave me what i needed to
connect to something other than money
it reminded me of the brotherhood it
reminded me that i had fallen in love
with these guys as human beings that
there was something more than money
there was something more than being a
clever marketer
that i remembered for a second who i am
the things that make me unique
that i have a desire to connect that i
actually enjoy communities that i'm not
a guy with a killer instinct i'm not
interested in stepping on my cons my
competitor's necks that's just not how
i'm wired
i'm wired to build something i'm wired
to see people shine i love seeing other
people win i think it's incredible now
that doesn't mean that i don't want to
win i want to win at the absolute
highest level i want to be the greatest
of all time
i want more people to write about me
going to mars because they're terrified
to try to match my intros
i want that right and i hope each and
every one of you wants to play at that
level i hope each and every one of you
looks at the greatest of all time and
says if i'm willing to break myself and
have to get there i could do it
but being honest with who you are being
honest that if there's something else
that you want to bring to the table that
you find a way to do that and so i said
guys i will come back and work with you
on one condition
i will never
prioritize money again
my highest value in business is
camaraderie
and at the time that was sacrilege we
had made a pact with each there was
three of us the three of us had made an
actual pact that we would do whatever it
took to make our technology company more
profitable and if that meant skipping a
family vacation if that meant waking up
at 2am on a saturday to meet and
brainstorm we did it
both of those stories are real we did
things like that i would go away with my
wife for christmas to see her family in
london and i would literally take a
camera with me so i could watch
the company
back in la
i've never switched off i didn't take
days off i was working no matter where i
was i was working seven days a week i
didn't take a real vacation meaning that
i wasn't actually working while we were
on it for six and a half years
no matter how
successful the person is that you're
looking at and wishing you could be like
them and thinking that they have
everything all figured out the one thing
that i can promise you is that all of us
struggle on the inside that is just a
reality of the human condition once you
understand that that is a reality that
that's just a part of the human
condition
then you can begin to ideally let
yourself off the hook and that you're
not spending a lot of time
stuck there but to give you a specific
example from my life the biggest one the
most harrowing one that i went through
was in film school so
uh
to cut a very long story short i went to
film school believed that i had innate
talent i went into film school with a
fixed mindset
i did very well at the beginning of film
school and that all to me felt like it
was proof that i was right that i was
naturally gifted that i was a born
storyteller and that i was gonna go and
have an illustrious career and i
actually went through a fascinating
period in film school where i was both
terrified that secretly i wasn't good
enough and but at the same time actually
believed that i was naturally gifted and
this is what i was meant to do and
every bit of feedback that i got in
either direction was
it made me believe to the core of my
being that it was true so when i would
do something poorly i would think see
that part of me that was convinced that
i actually don't have talent you were
right and then i would do something well
and the part of me that believed that
was like see i knew it you were born for
this and it all came crashing down as i
work my way up the ranks at usc film
school
only four people are chosen to direct
what's known as a senior thesis film or
a 480. and i was one of the four people
picked and i was like see i knew it man
i'm born for this of course i got picked
to do one of the senior thesis films
that just makes sense i'm i'm that good
and i thought okay cool the thing that
makes the thesis film so important is
the film school pays your budget to make
this film so at a time where there's no
youtube there's no iphones like filming
is an expensive endeavor
here you've got somebody that's paying
for it and that becomes your calling
card to the industry so
george lucas famously made one of these
films and obviously we know how his
career ended up working out and they
showed us his 480 by the way and it was
amazing
it was amazing and so
you could see that here was this gifted
filmmaker and so i have that in my head
like look at george lucas's films
absolutely brilliant he's gone on to
have this brilliant career i'm gonna
make an equally brilliant film or maybe
a little more brilliant and then i'm
gonna go become the next lucas or the
next spielberg and i'm gonna take that
film and get my three picture deal
and
i proceeded to
run smack bang
into one immutable truth and that was
that i wasn't a talented filmmaker
and i don't say that to be humble i say
that out of truth because i didn't have
the skill set to make a good film once
the level of complexity had gone beyond
a certain level so i had thrived in
these really short really simple films
and then once you're talking actors and
dialogue and you know the things that
would come close to what we would
recognize as a normal film
i had no idea what i was doing
and
try and try as i might i couldn't figure
out how to make the film come out well
and it didn't come out well and i was
mortified and i was embarrassed and i
never wanted anybody to see that film
and i was really and truly devastated so
i want you to imagine your whole life so
what i graduated at like 22. so
from 12 to 22
all i knew was i wanted to be a
filmmaker and my whole life was moving
towards that and it looked like i had
the natural gift and of course if you're
going to be an artist you're either born
with it or you're not right that's all
anybody said i can't express enough
in the 80s and 90s when i grew up
when people talked about art you either
had it or you didn't and that was that
there was no sense of growth mindset
carol dweck had not written the book yet
and so it wasn't even like i knew there
was a growth mindset and a fixed mindset
i just knew you're either born with it
or you're not
the great news was i was born with it
here we go it's gonna be amazing and
then boom i can't do it and i realize oh
my god i wasn't born with anything i
don't know how to do this there is a
tremendous amount of process to this art
and i don't know that at all but of
course as i'm in the middle of it i just
think my world has come crashing down
i'm not gifted i will never be gifted
and therefore i will never be a
filmmaker i will never make anything of
myself and just it was a downward spiral
of epic proportions
and
at the height of that
i would
go home from my dead-end job
and i would lay
face down
on the carpet because i couldn't afford
furniture
and
literally just sit there i can still
feel
that cheap nylon carpet and the way that
it felt on my face
as i laid there thinking well
my life is effectively over certainly
the
my life that was working towards a dream
is over
and
now it's just about finding a way to uh
be the smartest person in the room
and if that means that i have to go and
work a dead-end job to be the smartest
person in the room then that's what i'll
do and so i used to go
an interview for jobs having nothing to
do with film
because i felt totally broken and
my goal was to at some point in the
interview have the interviewer say
you're so smart why are you interviewing
for this role and because i had a fixed
mindset and i so needed that praise from
the outside i was putting myself in
these super weird and
useless positions just to get that
little nugget of oh my god like you're
so smart
and i had to put myself in sort of worse
and worse company to get to that point
and
finally and i don't remember what it was
that
led me to this idea of brain plasticity
but somewhere in the depths of my
despair i realized
can we get better
maybe we can
and so i started reading about the brain
and that started to plant seeds in my
mind that maybe brain plasticity was
real and maybe i could get better and
just because i wasn't good at film today
maybe i could get better at film down
the road and i ended up getting a job
teaching film because remember those
that can do those that can't teach so i
felt like okay well i can teach this
even if i can't do it and then so
between reading about the brain and
realizing wait a second
if i work at this thing i actually get
better my brain actually changes and i
become better at something and
given you know having gone through
however many years of schooling i'd been
through i started thinking about like
wait a second you would come into any
class and the funny thing is as a kid i
remember every grade just being
absolutely terrified that well i did
okay at being a fourth grader but mom
i'm gonna get devastated as a fifth
grader i don't know what i'm doing and
no matter how many times my mom would
console me and say remember they're
gonna teach you
how to learn the things that a fifth
grader needs to know they don't expect
you to already know it it just wouldn't
sink in and so i was sort of back in
that moment of
you know i don't know how to do this
but maybe
my mom is right maybe the
neuroscientists are right and maybe i
can learn
to become that thing i want to become i
start teaching film
and as i'm teaching it i realize wait
i'm helping my students become better
filmmakers so if i can help them become
better filmmakers and brain plasticity
is really true then i could get better
as a filmmaker myself
and that
that realization changed the rest of my
life and this is why i
am so obsessed with the idea of a growth
mindset and brain plasticity because the
biology backs it up
and once you understand it's what i call
the only belief that matters the only
belief that matters is that if you put
time and energy
into getting better at something
you'll actually get better have very
clear goals it always freaks me out most
people stop at the first sort of vague
notion of what they want to do i'm going
to punch myself in the mouth if somebody
comes up to me again and says i want to
help people
that's rad that comes from a beautiful
place like i totally get it but that's
like coming to me and saying i want to
win an olympic gold medal awesome winter
or summer
summer fantastic swimming or tennis
swimming excellent
backstroke
freestyle like at some point it's got to
get so specific because you have to know
what skills you need to acquire you have
to work backwards from the goal and the
goal has to be hyper-specific so if
boredom is the number one killer of
entrepreneurs that they're not able to
make it through the next one is they
don't have clear goals and the worst
part is they think they do
that's the part that terrifies me the
worst part is they think they do
until you know
exactly what your mission is and exactly
what your business model is and what
problem you solve what very concrete
problem that people are freaking out to
have solved until you do that you don't
have the necessary ingredients to build
your business
all right don't be romantic be pragmatic
look at the data the data will tell you
what to kill the data will tell you
what's working and what's not
this was the single best piece of advice
that was ever given to me and i ignored
it for three years i'm so embarrassed by
that that i always make sure any talk i
give people hear this
know more about your product
service industry
whatever than anyone else
than anyone else
if you guys have ever seen my interview
show
the reason that it's doing as well as
it's doing
is i know more about the guest
one guest actually said this i know more
about the guest than their mother
i just put in more work than their
mother
that's the truth
i go out and i research and i read
everything and i watch every video that
i can and so i know so much about that
person i know i'm gonna give a different
interview than anyone has ever given
before because nobody's done that level
of research not only does it blow the
guests away and totally endear them to
me
but it gets us to the point where we can
give an interview that has unique value
so know more about what you're doing
than anyone else in the world and grind
baby grind for two years for two years
that's what i look like every day
hair net lab coat gloves
put in the
work put in the work and this is where
the rubber meets the road this is where
you're really going to separate
the people that are entrepreneurs from
the people that are real entrepreneurs
you've got to want to grind you've got
to learn to love that you've got to
learn to love to put in the work to be
proud of yourself that you showed up and
put in the work to be proud of yourself
that you taught yourself how to suffer
to be proud of yourself that you're
developing a mindset where you believe i
can do anything i set my mind to and by
the way
once you believe
that you can do anything you set your
mind to without limitation how you spend
your time
becomes a spiritual consideration
how you spend your time becomes a
spiritual consideration because you
could be doing something if you want to
end hunger and hunger
what's stopping you bill gates is
actually going to end malaria he's going
to do it because he had the tenacity to
generate the resources and because he
has a mind that allows him to work on
the infrastructure and figure out how to
actually solve that problem
do not under any circumstances make bill
gates or anyone else extraordinary to
let yourself off the hook
don't do it don't sell yourself short
and this is where i see people go wrong
all the time they look at somebody who's
amazing
and they say well they're just naturally
gifted
i could never do that
you couldn't do it because you believe
you can't and because you believe you
can't you don't start putting in the
work
michael jordan got cut from his high
school basketball team
he wasn't exactly showing all the
promise in the world my own mother when
i left for college quietly assumed i was
going to fail and didn't admit that for
years
i showed no early signs of promise
i actually have a version of this
talk where i show photos from my
childhood and people like yeah you just
look stupid
and it's true i used to dress like a
clown and i mean that almost literally
so my waist was size 36
and i wore a size 54 pants
i wore literal jester hats
um i had one of those big chains that
connected to my belt
i had shoulder length hair
i did not exactly look the part and i
didn't take myself seriously
it really is a game of transformation it
really is a game of understanding that
you can become something so even though
i didn't start with the requisite skills
even though i wasn't a born entrepreneur
which is why i start this tale with that
even though i wasn't a born entrepreneur
i could acquire and did acquire the
skills that were needed to execute
it is a very long
road that leads you here
right now
most entrepreneurs in the world are
thinking about one thing
winning a championship ring
so to make progress and to fail forward
to really figure out when you make this
catastrophic error
you have to conceptualize it in the
right way so when you're trying
something recognize that as a hypothesis
so number one is to recognize i have a
goal my goal is over there i'm here
there's a gap between my goal and i i
need to know what that gap is i need to
understand it i need to know what the
impediment is i need to recognize why if
i just keep doing the thing that i'm
doing now why am i not going to get
where i'm going okay so first you have
to identify that now once you identify
that then it becomes a question of what
is your best guess which we will call
which is called a hypothesis so you make
that hypothesis which again is just your
best guess as to what you would need to
do
it's very important this isn't thinking
we're not going to live in the abstract
that when we finish this it's going to
tell us to do something so what would i
need to do
in order to overcome the obstacle that
stands between me and my goal if your
major goal is like way down the road
you're going to have to break it down
into smaller goals and so this goal with
my next 15 minutes is how i tell people
to think of it when you understand your
goal clearly enough and you understand
the impediments clearly enough you know
exactly what you should be doing with
the next 15 minutes
okay that's the level of clarity that
you need so okay cool
i've identified this
what the thing is that i believe i need
to do it's a guess
don't wait for lightning to strike don't
wait for anything to be self-evident
you have a best guess as to what you
should do with the next 15 minutes
and then your 15-minute stack up to your
best guess you know over uh a week or a
month or a quarter you know whatever
however big that project is
then you're going to do that thing
so i have a hypothesis on what would be
the most efficient way most effective
way for me to overcome this obstacle and
then i'm going to do that thing
and that thing is either going to work
or it's not
and if it works amazing did it work as
well as it could have
if not and i have to do this it's
something i have to do again then refine
and do it again if it did then what's my
next obstacle and i'm going to do that
one now eventually you're going to do
something and it doesn't work it either
you stood still or you made so little
progress as to be
unworthy of celebration or maybe you
even move backwards maybe this is that
moment where you totally embarrass
yourself maybe this is something that
happened down public and now you look
like a total ass
and in that moment you need to go okay
why
did this not work okay so this is where
we analyze the data
now the key to analyzing the data is
before you run this experiment you need
to say what success looks like so all
right
if i think here's my best guess as to
what i need to do to overcome this
problem
and here is what success will look like
so um let me give you an example
we had a hypothesis i still can't
believe that this is true but it is we
had a hypothesis here on our youtube
channel that
if we put
guests
if we took a photo of them or pulled a
screenshot from the episode where
they're doing something with their hands
that the click rate will go up and that
the click rate will positively impact
our monetized views okay so that's our
hypothesis we test it
i still can't believe this is true but
it works and it doesn't just work most
of the time it works almost all of the
time now nothing is you never have one
blanket statement where it truly works
for everything but i'm talking north of
95
so hey we had this hypothesis it worked
we did it now the number of times where
we had a hypothesis hey uh
put make the text white with a um drop
shadow
we tried it and that didn't work and
it's like wow i can't believe that
didn't work it looks so much better than
black text
but it keeps losing over and over and
over so in that moment it's like okay
well i really thought this was going to
work but it didn't work and you try
something else now when it's something
where there's a motion involved that
gets harder for people to get clear on
what the data is and that's why you have
to have a
a very clear understanding of what
success looks like now let's talk about
the more important part which is earning
credibility with yourself
this was one of the big breakthroughs in
my life was realizing that if i said i
was going to do something
and i wanted to give up on it
i would think about well if i position
it this way if i move this way if i kind
of hide this from that person and sweep
this under the rug over here then i can
still manage other people's
beliefs about who i am
and as long as other people think that
i'm cool i'm good i'm talented i'm smart
whatever then i'm good
and what i realized is a that only works
fifty percent of the time so fifty
percent of the moves that you make to
try to um
manage your
persona
50 of the time it works the other 50
percent of the time though people see
through it and then you begin to earn
the reputation of being a bull artist so
what i realized was okay not only does
it not work as well externally as i
think but it doesn't matter what the
outside world thinks if i don't think
positively of myself so
that became my obsession is
understanding credibility is
most important when you're talking about
self-credibility and how we earn
credibility with ourselves is by saying
i'm going to do this thing and then
doing it and then you just keep inching
that out farther and farther and farther
until you get to the point where you
show up for yourself in the most extreme
and difficult of circumstances so i'll
tell you guys a story um at my old house
i used to have this painting of the
michael jordan flu game hanging above my
fireplace and
that
was so inspiring to me and i always said
i put that up there to remind myself of
what i'm capable of and how i would
react if i were put in a championship
game situation and then lo and behold
flash forward probably a year later and
i actually get the flu and i have a
double episode the next day
and i remember i had a fever i was
rocked i could barely stand up it was
really miserable and i had to do all the
prep the day before for the episodes
and i was like i actually don't know
if i'm going to be able to make it
through this like it that's how sick i
was it's one of the sickest i've ever
been you need a goal
and that goal needs to be two things
exciting meaning you just like it there
is something about it that you find
motivational exciting whatever and then
the other part is it needs to be
honorable now honorable means that it
elevates not only yourself but other
people
the reason those two things are the
guaranteed one-two punch of success is
getting motivated is all about managing
your neurochemistry it's about knowing
how you wanna feel
figuring out the things make you feel
that way making sure that that feeling
is incredibly elevated so that you
really chase after that feeling the
reason that people do drugs is to
modulate their neurochemistry now the
great news is that you can modulate your
neurochemistry without needing to do
drugs but it requires you to invest
emotionally in things that matter to you
now the number one problem i see when
people are procrastinating is they are
not very excited by their goal
you have to take the time one to figure
out what it is that you like
what are the things that you respond to
kevin kelly has a really fascinating
idea that he calls not prematurely
optimizing you don't want to prematurely
optimize you don't want to pick a life
path
until you've explored
and understand what the things are that
you get a natural response from now
it's just going to be some degree of
like i like this thing it isn't going to
be oh my god the heavens open up and it
becomes clear what i should be doing
with my life it is way simpler than that
it is something that gives you more
energy than it takes now once you find
the thing that gives you more energy
than it takes now we can begin investing
in that and we go back to that initial
idea of i'm excited by my goal which is
very clear i know exactly what i'm
trying to accomplish
and it's honorable
now when you're doing something that
elevates other people you get in a
positive feedback loop because what
happens is you work hard to gain a set
of skills
that allow you
to move towards this goal that's
exciting and honorable and then you
start getting feedback from people
because achieving your goal even
pursuing your goal is helping other
people
by helping other people you get positive
feedback because you're getting that
positive feedback the next time you want
to lay on the couch you need only think
of them and the way that it makes you
feel to help people to elevate to push
yourself to go and get something done
all right that's the high level thing
then you want to put rules into your
life so that you don't end up wasting
time so that you catch yourself so for
instance the reason that i don't ever
find myself just laying around is
because i have a rule monday through
friday if i'm awake i'm either working
or working out now i've been very
careful to make sure that the things
that i'm working on are moving me
towards that goal that's incredibly
exciting and honorable so i'm getting
all the feedback from people by getting
good at this thing and adding value to
their lives and it was already exciting
i just found it interesting in and of
itself and then i have invested
emotionally over and over and over
focusing on the people that i'm trying
to help telling myself i'm trying to
help these people telling other people
embodying the emotion that i want to
feel and then i've got my rules to fall
back on i get out of bed in 10 minutes
or less monday through friday if i'm
awake i'm either working or working out
and those two rules as deceptively
simple as they are when combined
with a goal that excites me
and then the feedback loop of actually
being able to help other people creates
this thing where i get so much juice out
of it now you're gonna have different
rules maybe for you it isn't that monday
through friday you're either working or
working out maybe it's monday through
friday if you're awake you're either
spending time with your family or you're
working or working out whatever like
you're gonna make different allowances
for the things that matter in your life
but as long as you're doing those things
in their order of how you value them in
your life like you might say
monday through friday if it's between
the hours of 8 a.m and 5 p.m i'm working
if it's between the hours of 501 and my
bedtime i'm spending it with family rad
now you've optimized your life for the
things that matter to you you don't need
to try to match my rules you just need
to know your value system and put it in
order build rules that allow you to
actually accomplish that and then hold
yourself accountable
and if you're still not doing it at some
point we have to own that you just don't
want it badly enough and then we have to
refocus on desire is there something
that interests you enough that you can
work that loop of creating that
emotional connection in your life
and then that's where to start
you're having a biological experience
nature has those two levers pleasure and
pain
i think a lot of people make the mistake
of thinking well as long as i don't do
things
that create a problem i don't do bad
things i'll be fine
what could possibly be wrong
with sitting around
in my apartment all day
goofing off
watching tv
playing video games
all that stuff all individually
wonderful
but when you put it together
suddenly it does not give you the life
that you want and you start to feel
disease
you don't feel good something's not
right something's off
i don't know why i don't feel good and
then by the way you're probably eating
terrible food
and each bite individually is amazing
but it adds up to inflammation
dysbiosis meaning your
gut
bacteria your microbiome is out of whack
and it's sending
signals to your brain
that alter your brain chemistry and make
you not feel good something isn't right
but why don't i feel good i'm doing
things that are awesome
this food is awesome playing video games
is awesome
relaxing awesome
reading a book awesome
but life in total
not awesome
and how is that possible
because nature
has implanted directives in your brain
to ensure that you work hard because you
grew up on the
the plains of the savannah
and life was hard and life was scary and
if you weren't a part of the group you
were going to get eaten by something you
were going to die of exposure you
weren't going to make it
and so nature
by way of natural selection
has made it extremely pleasurable
to work really hard to gain a set of
skills that are unique and exciting to
you
that allow you to serve not only
yourself but the group makes that really
feel good even though it's hard even
though each step of that way is
difficult
and yet it adds up to something
extraordinary
okay it's it is the most
counterintuitive weird thing in the
world that if you do all of the
individual things that are fun it ends
up where you feel like crap and if you
do individually all the things that are
hard and a struggle and are difficult
you end up feeling awesome
that's a reality of life so i knew that
so even as i became successful i never
thought hey why don't we just retire it
won't work it won't work meaning work
because i won't be able to feel the way
that i want to feel i want to feel good
about myself i want to make progress in
my life i want to feel like i'm
contributing i know all of that because
i understand how the brain works i
understand how nature embeds these
directives in your brain and it isn't
enough to not do something bad you have
to be pursuing something that matters
meaning purpose that's it that's the
game it isn't success it isn't wealth it
is isn't adoration it's not trophies
it's not goals it's nothing other than
fulfillment and fulfillment is work
really hard
okay if it comes easy it won't work work
really hard
to gain a set of skills that you care
about that matter to you don't worry
about what everybody else thinks
skill set that matters to you and that
skill set could be playing video games
that could be how you're going to reach
and touch the world and elevate people
and show them what's possible and
entertain them absolutely great
you're doing something for other people
you work real hard to gain a set of
skills that matter to you that are
exciting to you
but they don't just serve you they serve
other people as well
in life
there are two ways to lose way number
one is to be weak to lack grit to be
emotionally unstable to be stubborn
that's where a lot of people fall in
their face they have these ideas in
their head and they're constantly
looking for things to affirm that
instead of doing what they need to do
which is constantly looking for ways
that you're wrong and once you start
seeking out ways you're wrong because
like i've gotten this far in life being
wrong what happens if i stop being
stubborn i start looking for ways that i
can learn more that i can get rid of old
ideas that aren't working for me and
really move forward and the thing that i
think is probably the most foundational
they have a fixed mindset now what is a
fixed mindset it means that you believe
your talent and intelligence are in born
traits you're born with it and that's it
and life is about making the best of
that and we're going to debunk
out of that the second way that things
can go wrong is they're chasing the
wrong thing
i'm telling you right now the punch line
to life
is not success it's not fame it's not
money it's not accolades it is very
simple it's brain chemistry aka
fulfillment the only thing that really
matters at the end of the day is how you
feel about yourself when you are by
yourself now we're not doing discipline
because our parents tell us to we're
doing discipline as a test to see if it
work to get us towards our goal now if
you have historically struggled with
putting discipline in place in your life
right now you're going to say but tom i
can't stick to discipline so why would
this work this time that's when we
realize one fundamental truth
this is a desire problem masquerading as
a discipline problem once you want your
goal
the way that a drowning man wants his
next breath
you will find discipline very easy to
stick to
and so learning to build your desire
for the goal that you have set for
yourself that becomes the incredibly
important part and the way to dial that
desire up is to do a loop and it goes
like this you're going to tell yourself
that you're very excited about this goal
you're going to tell other people that
you're very excited about this goal
and then you're going to embody
the feeling the amplitude that you want
to feel when you think about that goal
now there's a mechanism in the human
mind where it will justify the way that
you act no matter what i won't waste
time explaining some of the studies but
they are utterly fascinating about how
even people with damaged areas of the
brain will end up making up random ass
stories because the brain abhors a lack
of reason so the the brain will always
and forever make up some story about why
you're doing what you're doing and so if
you're responding hugely to something oh
my god i'm so excited about doing this
thing like i'm really amped up about it
and you're saying that to yourself and
you're saying it to other people and
you're saying it just like that
then the brain goes
there must really be something here
we've got this elevated level of emotion
amazing let's leverage that
and the brain doesn't say let's leverage
that but the brain will say okay we've
got this elevated level you're going to
leverage the fact that the brain says
that
to repeat it to reinforce and over time
you actually just will feel that
heightened level of emotion it's the way
the brain works what you repeat you
become
neurons that fire together wire together
things you do frequently including
embodying that amplitude of emotion
right lisa feldman barrett's book
how emotions are made talks about how it
starts with the body and then the brain
applies meaning to it so if you're
getting amped up you're excited the body
is saying to the brain yo like we're
amped we're excited we're doing these
things and the brain goes oh amazing it
must be because this really matters and
once you get the brain saying hey
we're this excited because it matters
you're firing those neurons together
the excitement around this thing so the
excitement and the pursuit of that thing
begin to mesh
and now we just over time have a an
actual desire to pull this off once we
have the actual desire to pull this off
then all of a sudden putting that
discipline in place becomes very easy
and that's the name of the game
you want to make it such that you want
it badly enough that the discipline
becomes easy to stick to because it's
going to move you towards that thing
that you really want
but you've got to learn
you've got to learn to want that thing
now
i'll give my typical disclaimer
this trick works incredibly well now it
only works on things you actually have a
legitimate interest in you couldn't
get yourself excited about something
that you truly just find stupid but
something where you actually do get a
natural response you actually are
naturally into that thing all we're
doing is dialing it up right so if it's
already a dial tone there's nothing you
can do to change the amplitude but if
the amplitude is already there and you
get this reaction we can really
exaggerate that reaction and build that
desire to get where we're going now
since that is the case you need to be
very careful what you apply this to
because you can end up really wanting
some stupid
i know from experience i dialed the dial
on my desire for money i cranked that to
a 20
and then spent eight and a half years
pursuing money only to come out
completely miserable so
don't waste your time dialing that up on
something that isn't exciting and
honorable meaning again honorable
it elevates you and other people not
just you
all right
be careful what you decide to want but
know that it's very powerful
how do you know when it's time to refuel
and choose self-care instead of
continuing to grind
physiological self-awareness is critical
i hear a lot of talk about people
developing psychological self-awareness
so understanding um
what you're good at what you want to do
all of those things incredibly useful
but understanding how to read your body
may be even more important than that so
lisa feldman barrett's book how emotions
are made
detail the way that emotions are far
more of a bottom up phenomenon meaning
they come from your body it isn't you
thinking about something and then
creating the emotion down that does
happen and of course you can spiral
yourself out of control simply by
thinking but usually what begins this
thinking process is a sense of unease
right anxiety is a bodily feeling often
times disconnected from what you're
thinking so figuring out ooh why do i
have the sense being able to process it
consciously we can pull it up into our
conscious mind and think through it with
words and logic but oftentimes it's
starting with that like oh man i don't
feel good about this and i don't know
why
so this is the fascinating thing about
drugs is drugs can either eliminate or
change the bodily sensation which then
changes the story that you're telling
yourself about the sensation now this
isn't an advertisement for drugs it's to
get you to understand that it can be
risky to sever the sense of body from
what you're telling yourself about it so
you want your body to give you this
description of what is going on but then
as you take conscious control of that to
develop that self-awareness around
physiologically what's happening you
need to understand why you're feeling
the way that you feel and so developing
that to get a sense of whether
this is a time to keep pushing through
or whether this is like one of those
moments where you actually really do
need to step back it's the difference
between sore muscles from you know a
nice hard workout and a torn muscle or
damaged joint from
an injury and the same thing is true
when you're thinking about how hard to
work how hard to push yourself you need
to figure out this fatigue that i'm
feeling this unease this anxiety this
stress is this a natural part of pushing
through the difficulties of this project
or is something else going on this is
now really starting to cave in on me and
what i need to do now is take a step
back
meditate
journal
hug my significant other pet my dog
cuddle my kids whatever the case may be
go for a run
but doing something that
slows you down
lets you take a deep breath
and the only way to figure that out
is to be able to interpret
the feelings that your body is giving
you
into conscious thought
okay and getting good at that loop is
very very important and it takes
practice it takes understanding what the
body is communicating why it's
communicating it what impacts it like
what you eat and drink has a huge impact
on what your gut is telling you and then
your brain tries to make sense of it and
it doesn't always go oh i'm feeling
anxious because in my case i was
drinking a zero calorie monster which
much to my dismay because i absolutely
love them
make me feel anxious and so
getting an understanding of that
seeing that pattern was actually quite
transformational because i stopped
drinking them and my anxiety levels
plummeted
by like 70 it's pretty crazy didn't take
me to zero but it made it a phenomenon
that was easily manageable through
meditation
so
this is where you have to develop that
awareness that pattern recognition and
be able to say oh i feel this way
because of xyz thing happening at work
or with my spouse or
with food that i'm consuming so be very
thoughtful about that and that will then
help you determine whether it's we need
self-care or we just need to push
through what steps can i take to bring
my focus to the one thing i'm working on
while blocking out all else
all right
so
the real key is you've got to learn to
compartmentalize so what i do to begin
my compartmentalization is i create a
list of all the important things that i
should be working on
i put that list in order this is very
important getting good at prioritizing
is an art form it is critically
important that you get good at that art
form and as you begin to break things
down and put them in order now you can
tell yourself hey this is what i should
be working on right now so rather than
trying to digest all the different
things that have to be done it's i'm
focused on this one thing right now and
my only job right now is to focus on
that thing and so by not letting your
mind wander and this meditation is very
good at bringing your focus back to the
breath which teaches you to bring your
focus back to whatever so i've got a lot
of things many things competing for my
attention but i know what my important
things are i'm working on the number one
thing right now let's say and so up this
is my entire world and if i find myself
wandering i bring myself back now part
of the reason that i can invest so
heavily in that is because i have the
belief that that's the most effective
way to work so
since behaviors follow beliefs you want
to make sure that you put that belief in
place which is true by the way that you
can do
everything that you want to do just not
all of it at once so everything has to
be done sequentially you can't do
everything at the same time and this is
why you have to prioritize things out so
if we know
that multitasking is actually a myth and
that you can put people in brain
scanners and what you're seeing people
who seem like they can multitask what
they're doing is called rapid switching
so they don't have what i have which is
high switching costs when i get in a
flow man i can go and go and go but
if i try to bounce back and forth
between things then i pay this high
price and inefficiency between the
switching costs of moving from switching
from that task to this task so i focus i
stay on one thing i have them in order i
know what i'm working on i remind myself
that i only have one job in that moment
that is to work on that thing i know
that that's the most efficient way to
work and i know that i'm good at
prioritizing things so it becomes very
easy boom boom boom and then you just
hold yourself accountable to actually
doing that
practice makes perfect you might have a
difficult time in the beginning start
meditating if you need to to train
yourself to come back to the breath over
and over and over and then you can just
apply that to whatever you're working on
come back to the project
the reality is
that those who can delay eating the
marshmallow the longest do the best
because you're right delaying
gratification is an absolute superpower
now one of the most extraordinary
experiments was done at stanford
university it's called the marshmallow
experiment there's a whole book written
on this utterly fascinating they've
followed the participants in the study
for like 25 years
absolutely incredible they bring these
kids into a room they give them a
marshmallow and they say hey you can eat
the marshmallow now if you want
but
if you wait until i come back
then i'll give you two marshmallows so
it's basically double your money it's
not going to be that long
now what the kid doesn't know is that
the researcher isn't coming back and
they just want to see how long the kid
is going to wait until they eat it they
do eventually come back but they leave
them really to struggle for quite some
time
and
what they found was the kids that could
come up with games whether singing to
themselves not looking at the
marshmallow whatever the kids that were
able to delay the gratification the
longest ended up doing the best they got
the best grades they got the highest
paying jobs they had the most successful
relationships now the reason that that
works is in any one moment if you're
just operating
around optimizing for momentary mind
states brain states neurochemical states
then you're always going to be in
short-term thinking you're always going
to get short-term results if however
you have this
goal that excites you and is honorable
and you're able to push through all the
boring stuff and all of that then what
you get is a set of skills that allow
you to do things other people can't do
and as we established in the last
question if you can do things other
people can't do that is by its very
nature success and you will be rewarded
in a way that other people will not be
rewarded because they can't do the
things you do and as long as the things
you do are valued by society then you
are always going to do very well
but that ultimately is the key you have
to be able to delay gratification now
for me understanding that that was
the nature of things that if i can delay
my momentary wishes for something longer
term then i could get these
very different results that separated me
from other people and because i'm
excited about what i'm pursuing i use
that excitement as my trick to stay
focused when things get boring and i've
said many times that boredom kills more
entrepreneurs than failure so everyone
will tell you that fear of failure is
what stops people and that is a huge
deal but honestly like i think it's the
fact that people don't want the outcome
badly enough to fight through all the
boring
painful stuff that you have to go
through to get to the other side to
ultimately be successful so
make sure that you are hyped up on your
goal if you're not then you're not going
to be willing to go through all the
difficult things where should a person
start with improving their self-care if
they have low self-esteem do you think
leveraging one
can directly improve the other okay
you've really got two issues here
but they are inextricably linked
you've got biology you've got psychology
the self-care is largely going to be a
question of biology getting the sleep
eating a diet that
at a cellular level is serving us at a
microbiome level is helping us at a
cognition level is helping us right
setting us up for success meditating
making sure that we get that background
stress and anxiety radiation down to
zero
huge in terms of getting you into a calm
and creative space so that you can think
through difficult problems
all of these things are
what you're going to
need to do
if you want to do well in your life now
self-esteem
is a whole other issue self-esteem has
everything to do with what you think
about yourself when you're by yourself
now you have to earn your way to that
and so the key to earning your way to
that is to figure out what is your value
system
what do you value what do you think is
the way that people should be spending
their time and their energies and then
are you doing things in accordance with
that and then there are things that are
baked in that are innate so there are
these innate drivers given to us by
evolution uh hard work the desire to
contribute to the group
meaning and purpose deep connection with
other people that we love okay these are
you have that imperative there is
nothing that you can do to shake that
imperative and so understanding how it
works and understanding how you need to
meet the needs of that if you want to be
fulfilled and be joyful is critically
important so as you go about teasing out
whether you have a self-care issue a
biological issue a self-esteem issue
something that is
either we're not addressing the
imperatives to contribute which is sort
of the easiest one to go to
or
we've let the self-care get so
out of whack we're not sleeping we're
not doing all of those things that it's
really beginning to
debilitate us from doing the things that
we need to do in order to build up our
self-esteem now your self-esteem is
really built around the framework of
congruence i said i was going to do it
i'm going to do it so that when you say
you're going to do something you
actually do it and then whether that's a
promise you make to yourself or to
somebody else and then the
fulfillment formula which is to work
really hard to gain a set of skills that
are unique to you and matter to you or
exciting to you
and that they serve not only yourself
but other people
and so if you're doing that working
really hard to get exceptional it's
something that matters that the world
cares about and that you love and then
you contribute in a way that elevates
you and other people that's the game of
fulfillment and so if you're doing that
i think you will find that that will
take care of self-esteem but if you're
not doing that if you're not finding
ways to contribute to the group if
you're not progressing in your life then
you're going to really struggle with
that so
you do the self-care to make sure that
you can actually build the self-esteem
by contributing in that way
and then those two things work
wonderfully together but you have to
recognize that they really are two
separate issues and they both need to be
addressed
i know
that what matters in life
is how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself
and that how you feel about yourself
when you're by yourself is largely a
function of your identity what you
believe to be true about who you are
and i know that it is critically
important to earn credibility with
yourself
and to earn credibility with yourself
when you say you're going to do
something you must do it and if you
don't then you won't have credibility
with yourself you won't
be able to respect yourself and
unfortunately you probably won't have a
lot of self-worth
one of the keys to developing self-worth
is to recognize
what you think is worthy
and then to do that
and so doing that thing is going to
become
incredibly important
and that's why i have these rules in my
life that's why i focus on identity now
there's a statement i use to understand
where my identity is which is i'm the
type of person that i'm the type of
person that when i say i'm going to get
out of bed in 10 minutes or less i
actually get out of bed in 10 minutes or
less now that makes me feel good about
myself
i'm the type of person that
believes so much in what he's building
that monday through friday if i'm awake
i'm either working or working out
right so you
build these identity statements into
your life that when you adhere to them
they make you feel good about who you
are they represent something in your
value system that you believe to be true
and worthy
and when you do that and then you adhere
to those things then you're going to
feel way better about yourself and the
desire to capture that feeling about who
you are over and over and over becomes
the very thing that propels you out of
bed and gets you going and moving
towards your dreams so i cannot stress
the importance of that enough so first
of all
you want to set yourself up in the way
that we were talking about earlier to
make consistency the default answer
so
we go to bed at the same time we have
our meal plan prepped out so we don't
have infinite ingredients in the house
and a bunch of junk food it's like we
have the ingredients we need to make the
food that we want to make our gym
clothes are right next to the bed all of
that stuff
so we are setting ourselves up so that
the right answer is the easiest answer
and the pantry is an easy way to explain
that if you don't know what you're going
to eat you don't have rules around what
you eat and you've got a bunch of junk
food in the house the odds of you
sticking to your diet are basically zero
because you don't have things laid out
you have not said this is what i eat for
breakfast this is what i eat for lunch
this is what time i eat this is what
time i stop eating all that stuff
put rules in your life
by according to that
live according to that and then keep
that list of the things that you know
that you're supposed to be doing okay
it's very important for you to make the
right choice the easy choice as you do
that in multiple areas of your life and
just start ruling things out and this is
again where bright lines really come in
handy you have to have things you don't
do as much as knowing what you do do and
a lot of people get themselves in
trouble because they don't have these
bright lines there aren't things that
are off limits so for instance monday
through friday if i'm awake i'm either
working or working out so you can
imagine if i start goofing off
i start playing with the dog i
play video games i would know
immediately that i'm not doing what i'm
supposed to be doing because is it
monday through friday yes
am i working or working out no cool then
you're doing the wrong thing and so by
having these rules and writing them down
can be really useful having these rules
writing them down knowing exactly what
you're trying to accomplish and why
you're trying to accomplish it because
remember you don't want to live the way
that i'm describing unless it's in
service of something you love that
you're excited about that you believe in
that you want it
because when you want that stuff none of
what i'm describing is a pain in the ass
you're excited to have these rules
because they're actually allowing you to
get done the thing you want to get done
and the more you engage with it the more
exciting it is the more your passions
are ignited because you're getting good
at something you're making progress and
something we haven't talked about
make sure your goals
are exciting and honorable they're
exciting you just want to do it it's fun
this is an area that you like to be in
and it's serving people in a way that
elevates not only yourself but other
people
okay
when you're working your ass off to gain
a set of skills that allow you to serve
other people in a way that's fun
now you've really got something if you
hear me talking about all this and i'm
saying apply it to a thing that you hate
that doesn't make any sense
but when you apply it to something that
you believe in and you have to do that
work
you have to decide to attach that
meaning and purpose to that thing
but when you do that now all of a sudden
working hard and being a badass and
seeing who you're becoming
that is amazing
as tony robbins says progress is a
foundational pillar to human happiness
make progress
make progress and you will feel
amazing
discipline isn't meant to make your life
suck as jackal willing says
discipline equals freedom
the point of these rules and all of that
is to know you're not going to quit
and you're not going to quit on
something that you care about something
that matters to you something that
you're building towards that is
improving your life and giving you a
sense of joy
unfortunately joy is not easy to come by
all of the default answers are going to
lead you somewhere negative and the
reason they lead you somewhere negative
is because nature has hardwired you
to work really hard to gain a set of
skills that allow you to serve not only
yourself but other people nature has
hardwired you for that so if you fail to
do that you sit around just playing
video games all day and i love video
games but i don't sit around playing
them all day
so if you're just sitting around staring
at the wall
getting lost in a book
working out all day and you never do
anything that allows you to serve other
people i promise you as much as you
don't want this to be true
you will not feel fulfilled
okay nature only has two levers to pull
pleasure and pain and if you're not
doing the things that nature has deemed
you need to do in order for you to live
long enough to have kids that have kids
you will have a profound sense of this
ease
and the only way to combat that is that
formula for fulfillment working really
hard to gain a set of skills that allow
you to serve not only yourself because
it should be fun for you
but also serve other people
you just have to
realize that there's more advantage to
holding yourself accountable all the
time
than to
hiding from it
not living up to your own standards
it seems like the right answer to you
know let yourself off the hook or to
make promises that you're not actually
prepared to keep because it's cool or
whatever it seems to make sense in the
moment
but going back to that idea of having
credibility with yourself is one of the
most powerful emotions you will ever
feel to respect yourself um is
it's one of the the pillars of
self-worth and if you don't have
self-worth
that is a really gnarly place to be and
so
it's very okay
to only make yourself very small
promises in the beginning and then we'll
widen that out slowly over time but that
was how i earned credibility with myself
in the beginning when i didn't have any
when i would say i was gonna do things
and then not do them when i would say
i'm gonna get out of bed tomorrow you
know really early and then i would lay
in bed for five hours which used to
happen all the time
so i didn't start by saying oh i'm gonna
get shredded or i'm gonna build a big
business it started with i'm gonna go to
the gym not even i'm gonna work out hard
i'm gonna go to the gym
and so then i would go to the gym if i
felt like walking out i would walk out
then as i found okay hey look at that
i'm being consistent i'm going to the
gym every time that i say i'm going to
go to the gym now
it's about okay well can i push it a
little harder than i did last time and
then you start doing that and then it's
like well can i set a goal for myself to
be able to lift a certain amount of
weight to look a certain way to lose a
certain amount of fat whatever it is you
want to do
if you start building on that making
slightly bigger demands over time you
know maybe you increment the demand
weekly and so it's like this is what i'm
gonna do this week and then the next
week it's a little more all of a sudden
a year later it's pretty extraordinary
you've had 52 increments of improvement
which is huge
so realizing that you get this
tremendous benefit from two things one
making what you promise yourself smaller
so that you know you can trust yourself
to do it and then two constantly like
bumping that out a little bit then you
actually get a huge reward so in in that
you have gotten better at something you
have moved towards a goal you have
actually obtained your goals that you
can set
over time you can set these bigger and
bigger more audacious goals and you can
actually reach them now when you know
that about yourself you have that
credibility with yourself
you know that you're going to stick to
it now when you set a goal it's like yo
this goal is exciting i'm amped up
because i know that i'm going to follow
through
and as long as you've built up that
muscle right the resilience
the ability to push through pain
boredom
when you have that
and you've built that resilience that
tenacity
now all of a sudden you don't want to
not be accountable to yourself because
you want to feel good about yourself and
you actually want to achieve those goals
man that's like if i could snap my
fingers and give people a gift it would
be to say hey the craziest dream that
you have you can actually make that come
true
the craziest dream that you have you can
actually make come true that's why
accountability is so joyful
if you want to do something
recognize there's no obstacle holding
you back other than what you choose to
believe
and if you want to be miserable it's
going to be there for you and if you
want to be empowered it's there for you
if you want strength it is there for you
it's a decision it's something that you
decide to believe in that you can get
strong
and that ultimately is the ultimate
strength to believe that you can
get better to believe that you can
become whatever you want to become so
choose optimism right now choose to let
it feel you choose to feel it to sit in
that sensation that anything you set
your mind to is possible when you allow
yourself to embody that to believe it no
matter what anybody tells you no matter
how many people tell you that you're
stupid you're a failure that you're
never going to do anything that you are
going to believe in yourself
if you can do that if you can choose
that optimism you can go anywhere
because you realize everything you
needed was in you all along
simply choosing to believe you could
execute against it
so have
that faith
go out and do it
you're setting your expectations too
high
you're triggering this sense of
inadequacy in yourself so i will tell
you that kicking yourself in the ass is
super powerful
but my rule is i never do anything that
diminishes my sense of self
why because it actually makes you less
effective
and effectiveness at moving towards my
goal
is the barometer by which i judge
whether something was a success or not
and if i have made a decision and it
moves me away from my goals because it's
making me feel badly about myself
because i've set a standard that's too
high i'm nitpicking myself to death now
i'm getting worse that's moving me away
from my goal and so i'm not going to do
that i don't allow that in my life
i don't allow it in my life i do not
allow myself to do things that diminish
my sense of self and move me backwards
so when i feel it happening
i'm like hey even if it's true even if i
am the biggest loser that ever walked
this earth reinforcing that in myself
will make me capable of less therefore i
don't do it i have a bright line in my
life that says i only do
and believe
that which moves me towards my goals
so
we're just going to
recognize as we set these expectations
that it doesn't make sense to do
anything that diminishes ourselves so
we're not going to set expectations that
are so high that we know that we are
bound to fail or
to set high expectations i love that
reach for the farthest star in the world
but don't value yourself for whether or
not you achieve it value yourself for
the sincere pursuit meaning you really
showed up you really tried to get to
that far star
to achieve some insane goal it was not
rhetoric you really showed up you got in
there you bled for this thing but the
whole time you're valuing yourself
you're cheering yourself on because
you're really trying you're the man in
the arena
covered in blood sweat and dirt
you might be getting your ass handed to
you but you're trying
and if you're trying then you should be
rewarding yourself and if you're
rewarding yourself then you should feel
better about it which makes you more
likely to get back in the ring and fight
and if that is the thing that leads you
towards your goals which of course it is
then we know that we are going to do and
believe in that thing because now we're
in the arena we're fighting our
behaviors line up with our desire to
achieve that goal
so
don't
worry about whether or not you actually
ever get there because let me tell you
success
cannot be guaranteed
struggle can you will struggle i cannot
guarantee that you will be successful
but the juice
is never going to be the success it's
never going to be the accolades just
as there is no feast so grand that you
will never be hungry again
there is no accomplishment so profound
that it won't be
fleeting no matter how big no matter how
much money you make
it will never be quote unquote enough
because you're playing a game of
neurochemistry and your neurochemistry
is designed to no matter how big your
meal was last time to get you back out
hunting again it's just how it works
all desire is like that it's cyclical
it'll feel awesome for a minute for a
day for a week maybe a month
but let me tell you you're going to want
to get back out there you're going to
want to hunt you're going to want to
accomplish again so don't value yourself
for that this is how people end up
making a billion dollars only to feel as
lost and empty as ever
you have a hole inside of you that can
only be filled with progress
meaning and purpose
it can't be filled with accomplishment
irony of ironies
but that's the way
an evolutionarily derived mind works
you have to be pushed to go on the
journey
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over
satiety
satisfaction
contentment
or anathema
to nature to survival
so of course
you're never going to be able to sit in
that
you're going to keep going again and
again and again and again
so
embrace that drive
accomplish
huge things
if you can
but only value yourself for the sincere
pursuit
the reality is if you want to achieve
something great in your life you've got
to be willing to accept who you really
are right now you've got to know exactly
what you're good at and what you're not
and the reason that the truth is going
to piss you off is it's going to hurt
it's going to hurt to acknowledge that
you're not yet who you want to be it's
going to hurt to know that you're not
yet capable of the things that you want
to be capable of and it's really going
to hurt
to know that the things that people say
behind your back the things that they
say to hurt you
that they're actually true
that they're right
they have a point you aren't good at
that thing you aren't as good as you
could be you did embarrass yourself you
have fallen down all of those things are
almost certainly true
but when you can look at those things
when you can stare nakedly at your
inadequacies when you can really
stop and not protect yourself with ego
but protect yourself by knowing that
you're going to learn from where you
failed you're going to learn from the
places you've fallen down you're going
to learn your inadequacies so that you
can build something new whoever it is
that you want to be no matter how many
times you may have failed at attempting
to become that person
leading up to this point you can still
become that person you're going to
decide who that is whether it's a
category like warrior or whether it's a
specific person that you want to emulate
you're going to break their world down
into do's and don'ts
how they would react to certain
situations you're going to hold that
ideal in your mind and you're going to
force yourself to act in accordance you
are going to tell people what you're up
to and if you really have some balls
you're going to tell people that want
you to fail
because that believe it or not that's
who's going to come to your rescue in
your darkest hours of wanting to give up
it's going to be remembering that out
there is someone who's laughing at you
who wants you to fail
that's talking behind your back about
how you're never going to achieve it and
then imagine how
rad it will be when you actually do
achieve it
there is the darkness and the light my
friends and you have to play in both
you've got to know 80 of your time in
the light focus on the beautiful things
you want to create and what you want to
do with your life and all that
there's 20 percent
some straight darth vader
like you've really got to lean into that
there is real power
in anger frustration in not wanting
somebody to get one over on you on
winning against all odds all of that
stuff it is really powerful and this is
one of those things that i find a lot of
times people are willing to lean on one
tactic but not the other this
set aside all your judgments about the
tactics
the human animal is designed a certain
way anger exists for a reason pressure
exists for a reason
a few things
one
happiness which is incredibly transitory
is probably not the right thing to focus
on the right thing to focus on in my
humble opinion
is
fulfillment and fulfillment has a
formula which is about working really
hard to gain a set of skills
that allow you to achieve a goal that is
both honorable and exciting so you have
to be hyped up about it and it needs to
serve not only yourself but other people
now that's a far more robust resilient
neurochemical state to pursue and i
should have said pursue a goal rather
than attain it because you may never
attain it but the pursuit of it ought to
be the part that is leading you to
fulfillment so you're working really
hard to gain a set of skills that allow
you to serve not only yourself but other
people okay so if we
know that that's what we want to pursue
then the question becomes how do we know
that we're fulfilled how do we know that
we're happy how do we know that we're
sad how do we know that we're anything
and the answer to that question is
really self-awareness and i mean
literally being aware of self so
understanding that emotions spring forth
from the body they are not a top-down
phenomenon the interpretation
of the emotion
is a top-down phenomenon but as lisa
feldman barrett details in her book how
emotions are made it's really a
fascinating
conversation it's probably the right way
to think about it between your body and
your mind and so your body is giving you
these feelings which are in part due to
values that you hold beliefs that you
have historical
experience your genetic composition
and then based on that
context
you feel literally feel a certain way
and then your higher level cognition
tries to paint a story
on top of that emotion explaining why
you feel it but the reality is is being
kicked up by your body and whatever
story you're telling yourself may or may
not be accurate but we believe the story
all the time and this is how people end
up in these negative spirals but you
have to learn to interpret those signals
from your body that's the important part
about assessing where you're at on an
emotional
playing field is you really have to get
good at interpreting those emotions
sticking with your good habits is
extremely hard because they're boring so
whenever something is boring it's
because somebody's pursuing something
that they actually don't give about and
that's the problem so for instance
eating healthy food all the time is
isn't
thrilling in the way that say eating a
bag of oreos is or black licorice which
is a personal favorite of mine or fried
food which is truly my weakness that
stuff is fun man you want to talk about
a dopamine cascade i could take a random
tuesday and make it feel like a saturday
night just by deciding that i'm going to
cheat on my diet
now i don't do that
i cheat maybe twice a year
so it is when i say it is crazy rare and
yet my life is full of things that
thrill me and i use that word on purpose
now what it comes back to is going back
to the whole topic of today habits and
how you stick with them even when you're
bored even when it's not interesting
anymore long after it stopped being fun
the very secret to habits is caring
about the thing that that habit is meant
to lead to but for real like really what
do you care about and for instance here
is a life i pass no judgment on
man because if this is what you
want
and it like you love it and you're
filled with fulfillment it's amazing
great if you want to sit at home all day
and you want to cut your life to the
absolute quick financially so that
you're living in
a tiny hovel with five other people
fine and you're eating tina's burritos i
don't even know if they still exist but
when i was way hardcore poor they were
awesome because it was three for 99
cents which was amazing
so i could live off of that and you're
cool you boil it down to nothing you
don't have a car no insurance nothing
and you accept that my life is going to
be shorter
than it would otherwise be and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to smoke weed a
lot and i'm going to eat bad food a lot
man respect like if you do it with your
eyes wide open and you're loving it and
you're having a great time it just the
only reason that you never hear me talk
about that stuff is
from my experience from what i've seen
of other people the only thing that
gives the human animal the
the best feeling which is to feel good
about yourself when you're by yourself
is to do the hard things
and to do things that bring fulfillment
and the things that bring fulfillment
are often born of momentary suffering
but they allow you to get stronger in
order to serve other people that's it
that's just what i've seen so i don't
think it's better than the alternative
that i just described it's just the only
thing that i've seen really lead to that
sense of like
deep fulfillment so
my thing about the the specific part
about the good habits are hard to stick
with because they're boring just you've
got to attach habits to things you
actually really and truly care about no
one can tell you what to care about you
can certainly build that into your life
you can take something that's an
interest and build it into something you
care deeply about uh which i've talked
endlessly about so i won't go into it
here but that is very very possible
associate your habits to that thing
suddenly the habits will be very easy
don't judge yourself live your life the
way you want
but respect the realities of
neurochemistry
as maya angelou said
if you don't like something change it
if you can't change it
change your attitude
that's some of the best advice you're
ever going to hear
at the end of the day you should always
be trying to change the things that you
have the ability to change
there are inevitably going to be things
that you can't change but you're never
helpless you're never a victim in that
moment you still
have the
unbelievable ability to choose to look
at it in a new way to choose to reframe
it and in that refraining you change
everything you don't just change your
own neural chemistry you're not just
changing the way that you feel you're
actually changing the way that you're
going to approach the problem something
that was moments before something that
seemed impossible something that was
breaking your will to continue to fight
with a change in attitude becomes
something completely different
and as hans selye said
adopting the right attitude can turn a
negative stress
into a positive one
and that game of mental jujitsu is what
it's about that game of flipping
something on its head of turning
something around of seeing it in a new
way so that you can act
in a new way
is how you make forward progress and
understanding that understanding the
need to take control of your perceptions
understanding that understanding your
need to change your perspective
that's how you begin to get ahead once
you understand your perspective is a
choice it is not objective truth burn
that into your mind it is not objective
truth the world that you see around you
is simply the perspective through which
you see it all of life is a fun house
mirror
and when you acknowledge that when you
understand that you're looking at a
distorted view of the way the world is
you realize that you can adopt a
different distortion you can adopt a
distortion that allows you to see things
more clearly that allow you to see
things in a way that empower you
and that should always be the first step
is figuring out not what is not what you
can change
but instead understanding what you need
to change it to
and understanding that that change comes
from inside you
it isn't a manifestation that you have
to make in the outside world first it's
a change you have to make inside
yourself it is a shift of perspective it
is simply stepping to the side of what
you're used to and how you're used to
seeing things and understanding that in
reframing things you take that negative
and turn it into something that builds
you up but you've got to choose
you've got to decide
you've got to believe
that you can do it
but once you believe that you can see
things in any way that you need to to
reach your goals your life will change
forever
because you'll actually reach your goals
[Music]
i want to dispel a myth for you
it's the talent myth
[Music]
it's the belief that some people were
just born with more than others that
some people are naturally gifted and
some aren't and that's just the way the
cookie crumbles and
whatever you're going to be is
essentially determined by how you
started that your dna is exactly your
destiny
i'm here to tell you right now
that's
it's just not true it's not the truth of
the way that humans are designed as a
species we're the ultimate adaptation
machine the very thing that puts us at
the top of the pyramid is our ability to
adapt it is the fact that the brain is
plastic that it responds to change it
responds to stressors it responds
to repetition
and repetition is a slave to obsession
[Music]
as conor mcgregor said there's no talent
here this is hard work this is an
obsession you could be anyone if you put
in the time
that's one of the greatest athletes of
our time telling you that he's not the
result of
genetics he's not the result of natural
gifts he hasn't been bestowed something
by god he has shown up day after day in
the most mundane of conditions on the
cold days on the hot days he put in the
work because he was obsessed
with what he could become and that
repetition that you need to actually
gain a skill follows that obsession so
in you right now right now today you
want to start building that obsession
you want to look at it like an ember
that can become a raging fire but it
needs your time and attention
it needs your time and attention you've
got to take that interest you've got to
take that spark of desire and you've got
to fan the flames you've got to turn it
into that obsession and from that
obsession if you put in the work if you
do the things day in and day out the
back breaking work pushing through the
pain fighting through feeling like an
idiot fighting through embarrassment
getting up brushing yourself off doing
it again practicing putting yourself at
somebody's feet and asking
what could i have done better
not look at the things you're doing well
but look at the things you're doing
wrong look at the things you're doing
poorly staring at your inadequacies with
no loss of pride
because the only thing you value in
yourself is your willingness to do that
your willingness to work your ass off
and as sylvester stallone said
i'm not the richest smartest or most
talented person in the world but i
succeed
because i keep going
and going and going
and that's the secret i think my goal
may be too big i write it every day but
it makes me feel heavy daunted and
terrified to pursue it rather than
excited okay that's powerful have i
chosen my goal poorly or or do i need to
man up okay
dude brian i love you so much for this
question in in this question is like
everything that people go through so
first of all your goal is not too big
okay you're just not yet the person you
need to be to execute against that and
that is absolutely fine i'm not yet the
person i need to be in order to rival
disney i know that and so every day i'm
waking up not saying am i there yet am i
there yet am i there yet i'm thinking
what's one really simple thing that i
can do right now today to learn
something that moves me down that path
or who can i partner with you know
what's the idea that i need to get other
people excited about what i'm doing so
that's super important so your dream is
never too big even if you said you want
to terraform mars i'm with you right
that's our boy elon musk is literally
thinking about that so your dream isn't
too big
you just don't think about like the end
goal and let it overwhelm you which is
what is happening to you you're writing
it every day okay so you're obsessing
about that end goal that end outcome
which first of all that end outcome is
about a thing like the thing that i um
think about every day is not building a
studio to rival disney even though
that's often what i externalize to
people what i think about internally the
thing that warms my soul is i think
about the people out there that
are extraordinary they could do
something amazing with their lives but
they won't because they don't believe in
themselves so what i think about the
thing that drives me that obsesses me
and fills me with excitement and joy to
get good enough to actually do it
is helping people develop an empowering
mindset
that's my obsession
the whole rival disney thing is a path
and i think it's the right path and i'm
excited to do it and i love it but at
the end of the day the thing that keeps
me going when i'm feeling overwhelmed is
helping other people so figure out what
that thing is that huge goal that you
have why you want it because chances are
that you're going to be able to do it in
smaller ways along the way as well so
it's not like this you know 20-year
chasm of of
binary nothingness where you're not at
all doing what you want to do and then
suddenly one day it either happens or
doesn't like you know winning the
lottery um that it's you know these
incremental steps okay so you write it
down every day start writing down the
beautiful thing that you want to bring
into the world and also even that like
you should be spending time what are you
grateful for right now thinking about
what you want to learn thinking about
things that excite you
makes you feel heavy daunted and
terrified to pursue it okay so if it
makes you feel heavy daunted and
terrified to pursue it because you're
obsessing over the end goal it's some
like traditional marker of success money
a big company whatever and not how you
want to help people then it's just a
matter of reframing if on the other hand
is because you think you're supposed to
want that thing but you don't actually
want it and so the idea of pursuing it
and all that you would have to do to get
there is just horrifying to you then yes
you've picked the wrong goal only you
can answer that question i have no idea
which of the two is true
just remember don't chase something
because people have told you that you
should want it literally just look at
what gives you more energy than it takes
now what i find is the thing that people
are always if somebody's going to
compliment me the thing that they're
going to compliment me on is tom you
always seem so prepared for your
interviews
and my thing is like
the only way to win in life is to be
more prepared than everybody else if you
want to win a gold medal in the olympics
you actually have to be better at that
sport than any other human being on
planet earth
that's business
you're going here's another one this
drives me nuts
people will say tom if i because i
always tell people you have to work hard
smart and long hours
and the inevitable question that i get
is
tom
if i work hard and smart
why do i need to work long hours
because you're going against me and i'm
willing to do all three
so now what
there there's no arbiter other than
being better right if your game is to be
stronger you better be able to lift more
weight
if your product solves xyz problem it
better actually solve it and better than
anything else so the presentation is hey
look guys i'm a nervous wreck i hate
giving presentations but the one thing
that i know about my product it will
outperform and i invite you now to put
me in whatever circumstance you need to
and i'm going to show you that it out
performs this is why trust me if albert
would let me i would stay here on this
stage and answer every single question i
would let people push me and say no but
tom you haven't solved my problem i will
keep going until we solve your problem
now i don't mind doing that because it's
first principles thinking it applies to
everything i know my product is better
so i will just stand here and do this
moment after moment after moment
when you get as confident in your
product as i am in my ability to solve
business problems
presenting will be very easy
when you were making your transition
into being successful how did you combat
the frustration of not being where you
wanted to be
i'm never where i want to be so i'm not
where i want to be now i'm not where i
wanted to be when
you know people would have looked at it
and said oh my god this is like the
height of success it was
one i'm very careful to make sure that
i'm only invested in the process
but because i'm trying to get somewhere
that intentionally i'm throwing way
beyond where i'm at i'm always thinking
about what it's going to take to get to
that next level i'm never where i quote
unquote want to be
but i don't trick myself into tying my
value to achieving it so i'm having fun
i'm enjoying the ride i'm in it for the
process i'm in it for the learning and i
make sure that i'm hand crafting my life
to
optimize for joy and fulfillment
and so knowing that i cannot guarantee
the success i cannot guarantee ever that
anyone is ever going to be successful
but i can
guarantee that you're going to struggle
guarantee
100 nobody avoids it that's it everybody
that ever tries to do anything and even
most of the people that don't try to do
anything are going to struggle
profoundly
with
moving forward it's just
hard like that
and so if you know that the struggle is
guaranteed then
you can't allow yourself to waste time
to be tormented by the fact that you're
not where you want to be
make sure you're having fun in the
struggle
figuring out how to struggle well that's
the answer
when i was coming up the question i was
told to ask myself was
if you knew you couldn't fail what would
you do
and what i realized is since failure is
the most obvious answer
that's probably not the right question
to ask
the right question to ask is what would
i do and love every day
even if i were failing
now failure is never going to be as fun
as winning i know that but
if you can do something that you believe
in enough and that the act of trying to
get good at it is fun in and of itself
now you're on the right path
that's where you want to focus put your
time and energy into making sure
that
you love
the process
don't worry about the outcome worry
about the process getting better and
loving that everything else will take
care of itself we're leading people into
the unknown we're leading them into
whether it's business danger or
emotional danger and at the end of the
day sometimes people are going to get
hurt they're going to fail whatever they
have to be resilient they have to learn
but if you're willing to do that if
you're willing to be the human
equivalent of a battle axe and get in
there try things hard things fail
practice get stronger
learn grow
then over time despite the scars
you are more capable
capable
capable you can do things other people
can't do
i'm obsessed with that idea i want to be
able to do things other people cannot do
now when you can do things that other
people cannot do
now you've got a real shot at
whatever it is that you're trying to do
i want to i want my name to echo through
the annals of history no i don't need
other people to want that
but i want that
and i know
for me to actually pull that off which
by the way my identity is not tied up in
that my self-esteem is not tied up in
that i could die completely unknown what
i value myself for is the pursuit but i
sincerely pursue that and to sincerely
pursue that i have to become capable of
things other people are not capable of i
have to be so good that i cannot be
denied that's my obsession i love that i
want that for you guys to both
be willing to play at that level every
day and yet not judge yourself if you're
not there yet that you only judge
yourself by the sincere pursuit of
something that you show up every day
playing to win trying to be the best in
the world at something that you care
about
being unafraid to lead to be out front
to fail people sometimes to own it to
say hey
i failed you
and this is why and this is what i'm
gonna do next time to get a different
result
and you will be shocked
at how people will follow you
more
when you just own it
when you tell them what your plan is to
get better and they see you on the front
lines improving
people will fall in line i
all the time
but on balance people see the rate at
which i improve
they see that i have a goal and i'm a
servant to that goal
and then i build skills based on what
will take me to that goal
and because i win on balance more than i
lose
people still follow
chaos can be very difficult to deal with
and it requires a lot of emotional
management and you've got to be able to
do many things quite frankly it's going
to be a whole grab bag of tricks my
friends for you to get through and get
on the other side of that chaos all
right first things first meditation is
going to be huge okay just at a
physiological level you've got to get
that background radiation down to zero
now this can be very difficult when
you're in the middle of something and
you really feel like you're fighting for
your life but you need to make time for
that this is a physiological process by
getting into that calm and creative
state you're going to find answers that
you otherwise wouldn't see so we need to
get out of that panic mode and into calm
creative problem solving now remember
action cures all so we've got this
fulfillment thing that we're chasing
we've got the fulfillment formula we
know exactly what we need to do we're in
the middle of the chaos
and the thing that's going to solve for
that meditation so we're thinking calmly
and clearly
but also
having a plan of attack and then going
after it so there's been really cool
studies done by andrew huberman and
other people about how lateral eye
movement can actually pull you out of
that
stressed and anxious state because what
it's doing is it's mimicking you moving
forward and moving forward on these
evolutionary time frames we've been
rewarded for that because it means
you're confronting your problem you're
working hard you're dealing with the
saber-tooth tiger the warring tribe they
just need to go out and hunt whatever
you're dealing with it and since nature
only has pleasure and pain if you're
dealing with it nature's going to make
sure to give you some pleasure on that
and conversely if you're trying to hide
from it that's not going to feel great
and you're going to really spiral it is
crazy to me how taking action and
getting into problem solving mode
immediately shifts me out of anxiety it
is absolutely profound so that's going
to be a big part of this and when you're
doing that in
the context of the fulfillment formula
now you know that this is going to be
something you're working really hard to
gain that set of skills that serve not
only yourself but other people so you're
thinking about other people you're
thinking about service and that has a
way of really helping you get through
the chaos because it's giving you the
emotional energy to have the stamina to
fight through to get to the other side
and as i think it was churchill that
said if you're going through hell
keep going
but keep going armed with meaning and
purpose around how you're contributing
to the group around getting these skills
around being in problem-solving mode and
around taking action because that is
going to be the thing that cures all and
then don't forget sleep hygiene very
important meditation important keep your
diet right don't tell yourself a
negative story don't allow yourself to
loop and defeat find people that can
elevate you find people that will
in a very real skills-based way
help you see the path forward and help
you
hold on to the only belief that matters
that you can figure this out this is one
of the most common frames ever worth
being good enough being right being
smart
because these are very fragile ways to
think of yourself and i understand the
temptation because it feels really good
when you do feel worthy it feels really
good when you are right it feels really
good to actually be the best at
something
but the truth of the world just the
truth of the world it is this way
you're always going to encounter
somebody better stronger faster more
pious more worthy more whatever
so if you live in a world of comparison
it will rob you of your joy
even people who like michael jordan if
you put him right now up against
most rookies the rookies going to win
rookies younger faster hungrier
michael's just lost his step he's gotten
old
so if he were trying to make his life
about his glory in that period
let's say he lives 80 years if he's
living for the glory of 20 years that's
the most heartbreaking life i can
imagine
so you're going to move in and out of
these moments where you are a badass to
where you're not a badass
don't value yourself for that
value yourself for something that is
anti-fragile
being smart being right being good being
worthy they are very fragile thanks
because sometimes you won't be it simply
is this way
valuing yourself for being a learner on
the other hand for trying
that's anti-fragile
because the more somebody attacks you
for being dumb
but you build your self-esteem around
learning
the first thing i think when someone
says i'm dumb is awesome in what way
because i view myself in these 10 year
windows
and i know
the same people that were laughing at me
when i became an entrepreneur knew
nothing about it and i was who's the kid
in the server room and i was the only
one with an office that had no windows
and there were like nine other computers
in my room and nobody knew who i was and
the only contribution i made to phone
calls was to say goodbye at the end of a
conference call i'm not kidding
10 years later
i own
a billion dollar business
who the is laughing now
it only worked because i didn't mind
looking stupid
it only worked because i wasn't asking
myself whether i was worthy or whether i
deserved it
i just asked myself am i leaving it all
out on the field yes or no
am i learning yes or no and if i'm not
i didn't go oh that makes me a bad
person
i went i need to change my actions to
get a different result
and once you start thinking like that
and you literally value yourself
for how hard you're trying how much
you're learning how willing you are to
accept when you fall in your face so you
don't try to get out from under it or
campaign to convince people that you're
better than you really are
on where you're at
because once you're real about it then
you can make progress but if your energy
cycles go to
yourself you'll never get out of it
steve wozniak okay co-founder of apple
computer with steve jobs
steve wanted to be an engineer he never
wanted to get to the point where he was
like the president of the company and
dealing with business meetings all day
he wanted to engineer he wanted to be in
there in the hardware writing the code
that was the thing that gave him juice
and the fact that he had the
self-awareness to understand i don't
want you to keep promoting me until i'm
running the company i want to be here as
an engineer in the thick of this solving
these problems that is going to be a
joyful life for me
so recognizing
what it is that you actually want what
speaks to your personality where are you
going to be most energized where are you
going to be the most alive
then put yourself there
and then pursue it with everything you
have in a joyful way where progress is a
key and that you can as you say step
into the fire
but i want to make sure that people
aren't blinding themselves to what they
really want the people are taking the
time to develop that self-awareness if
you can't say in a single sentence what
really fills your tank what gives you
that energy what makes you feel
alive
if you can't say that in a single
sentence you're in trouble
so journal
write about it
think about it
work on it
because
getting that right
is
critically important and what i see a
lot of times is people have a feeling
they never stop to ask what that feeling
is they never stop to ask where it came
from what it means they just have a
feeling that they should be doing xyz
thing
and they go pursue it sometimes with
their head down for a very long period
of time i know i did that
sometimes people never look up and they
spend their whole career pursuing
something that they don't love they
don't care about because they think
they're supposed to either the world has
given them that idea right we're living
through a time where being an
entrepreneur now is cool
and certainly not everybody is going to
enjoy that
we're
a social animal with a competence
hierarchy and progress feels awesome and
so often times people want to just
progress blindly without thinking about
do i need to progress within the
hierarchy of a company or do i just need
to get better at something so that i can
do things that other people can't do
because it's very different if you
gave steve wozniak the lowest you called
him the janitor but he creates the next
piece of game-changing technology
does its title matter or did it matter
to him that he got so good that he could
actually create that groundbreaking
piece of technology
now if you like the climb amazing climb
but if the climb is misery and
you're finding yourself in progressively
jobs that suit you worse which is why
they say that people rise to the level
of their incompetence because you end up
getting promoted until you get to that
job that you kind of suck at and then
you just stop
so if you know what you
love and want and where you fit in and
whether you want to be the person that's
leading or whether you want to be in a
pack and part of a community figure that
out about yourself
and then figure out how within that
framework what do i need to improve to
chase to do
all the things that i want to do that
make me feel alive
that's the key
that's how you embody your highest self
be honest about the 50
and then be honest about the 50 that you
can change
because your life will be unrecognizable
and i think
tony robbins is right that a
foundational pillar to human happiness
is
progress
this isn't about efficiency
i don't even think it's about peace of
mind
the way you go about setting a standard
is
what's the
lowest bar that you need to hit in order
to get to your goal
i mean that's really the question now if
your goal is i want to be proud and i
want to feel like it represents
the absolute
pinnacle of what i'm capable of today
okay i can actually get behind striving
to do that as long as it stays positive
my goal isn't for this to sell for a
million dollars my goal isn't for this
to
be
echoed in the annals of history my goal
is to create something that represents
the pinnacle of what i'm capable of
right now today
i can get behind that if that's your
goal get after it
if it is a project at work okay what do
we need to do in order to get the result
that we want who's our customer right
who are we trying to impress what do we
have to do to win people over again
going back to that idea of 80 20. a lot
of times 80 percent of the effort
gets you
where you need to go and going the extra
20 is really just wasted time because
there's no sort of additional benefit
like you got the job you sold the
product you did whatever now it doesn't
mean aim low
but it does mean that if the job gets
done
at
eight units of energy you're better off
applying the extra two units of energy
to something else
instead of again going back to that fear
of rejection nitpicking trying to make
it perfect unless again your goal is
how can i express what i'm capable of
right now in this moment but even then
it's got to be right now in this moment
you can't beat yourself up and oh my god
this isn't what i wanted it to be
it represents the best you can do right
now like if you've really given yourself
over to it and you've really tried again
rewarding yourself for the sincere
pursuit so you're rewarding yourself for
the sincere pursuit and the end product
represents the best of what you're
capable at right now
now if you want to be an olympian and go
on and get even better amazing
but remember it's the pursuit of the
championship performance that's
interesting
it isn't
winning a championship so getting in
there producing art by the pound as they
call it there's a very famous um
anecdote it's not quite a study but
there was an art teacher who had their
students do either one piece of art they
worked on it the whole semester turn it
in for a grade or
you can get graded on the pounds of art
that you produce over the semester
so every piece could be
trash
but if you have a lot of pounds then you
will get a good grade cool
one piece done really well or art by the
pound now what the teacher has found is
that the best piece of art
the best piece of art
every semester semester after semester
year after year comes out of the art by
the pound group
why
because they weren't worried about being
perfect and they actually got good at
art
they were taking things to that 80 stage
learning the lessons that they needed to
learn going another 20 isn't going to
teach them more about that piece
certainly not enough to warrant the
amount of time it's what's called
diminishing returns maybe they would
have learned a little bit more by going
the extra 20 of the way but they're not
learning enough to warrant the amount of
time and so by just getting in there and
producing and producing and producing
creating learning pushing trying new
things you broaden your skill set you
get a little braver you're more
courageous you're taking chances because
you know you can always do another one
now in that you're awash with all these
80 pieces where you're learning all of
this stuff and you just inevitably beat
the person that spent all their time
trying to perfect one piece
art by the pound
art by the pound
the meta goals should always be to get
better
so once you get to the point where
you've learned the lessons that you need
to do aha you had that aha moment
it's on to the next one
turn it in on to the next one
aim to have a perfect career
which is
full of
failure
embarrassment
and just
rich
with hard-won
skill
that's perfection we're chasing i'm not
in love with my job but i have no dream
or passion to succeed further
i don't know what else to do i feel like
this job has taken all creativity and
imagination away from me what do you
recommend for someone like me
all right so first and foremost
we are going to have to figure out
what exactly has happened
so
is it that you don't have a dream or
passion because you haven't taken the
time to
define that because let me be very clear
passion
is not
an archaeological dig
it's an architectural build
so you don't turn in words
look inside yourself and find this
glowing ember of passion and excitement
that's been sitting there since birth
despite that some people will tell you
that that's how this works but it is not
if steve jobs were born a thousand years
ago he would not have dreamed of making
the iphone
what ends up happening
is you decide
there is something that you decide means
enough to you that you're going to
invest in it
and then over time that investment turns
that thing into a
deep and abiding passion as you get
better and you get feedback from the
world that they value this thing that
you're getting better at
but it isn't just lying dormant within
you and this is like the number one
confusion that i encounter with people
is they think that
either they're broken and other people
were born with a passion and they were
not
or
they just think that
you know if i do enough introspection
i'm gonna find something sitting inside
of me
and finally my life will be amazing
once you realize that in fact what
happens is when you look inside all
you're going to find are these um sparks
of interest
and from that spark of interest
through pursuing it
as
a process of gaining mastery
it will become a passion
when you're able to use that skill set
that you gained in the pursuit of
mastery to serve not only yourself but
other people okay so doing that now
you're in this passion loop of you
worked really hard you gained a set of
skills allows you to serve other people
they give you feedback oh my god thank
you this is so amazing i'm grateful for
what you've done built created given me
whatever the case may be and that feels
good which makes you want to go get
better and that's the passion loop
now as you're doing that
you're able to
really be energized by the things you're
doing but
it doesn't start by looking inward and
finding something it starts by realizing
that you have to fan those flames of
that spark of interest to turn it into
the raging inferno that you want to feel
of that passion but that comes from that
loop
okay so that's the first thing to assess
now if you already have
or had a passion but this job has
somehow beaten it out of you that's a
very different story and so if that's
what's going on we need to figure out
what is it in the structure of that that
is robbing you of that what's going on
exactly that's making this overwhelming
or stressful or not fun is it politics
in the office is it just the work
environment is too fast-paced is it that
you're not being honest with yourself
about you know going back to this idea
fifty percent of you is hardwired fifty
percent of you as malleable if the
hard-wired part is out of step with the
life that you're trying to lead there
can be a lot of frustration there so
having the self-awareness to understand
did you put yourself in the wrong
position are you trying to be steve jobs
when you should be steve wozniak that's
a really imperative thing to look at now
i find that a lot of times
companies have their own issues whenever
you get a large group of people together
there are going to be weird things that
have to be navigated
but at the end of the day
while you can't control everything that
everybody does you can always control
how you react and so you can reorient
yourself within a company to figure out
one if there's a
path back to finding that joy but that
comes from breaking down what exactly
happened that made you stop feeling the
joy
and two
are you able to perform at a high enough
level that you're able to create the
space for you to get back on track
because if you're going to go in and try
to move things around and make some
changes within the company or within
your role or within how things work
you're going to need to be performing at
a very high level to have the
credibility to make that ask and this is
where it gets difficult nobody wants to
hear this i get it everybody wants to
point fingers and say this is just a
toxic company but in reality if it's
that bad leave do not waste time start
find another job first i'm not just
saying quit
find another job but get out of there
don't act like you're actually in prison
you are not actually in prison and yes i
understand that you have
obligations and you may be a single
parent with kids and huge responsibility
i completely understand and i have the
most empathy for that in the world but i
want you to understand
you are only as trapped as you allow
yourself to be if you have a useful
skill set you will be able to find
another job and now is the time to go
looking for that while you're still
getting paid
now if you don't have skill set that's
marketable that's where we have to start
and so
building up the skill set
so that we can be marketable somewhere
else that's going to give us the ability
to perform where we are or leave if it's
too toxic but assuming that we're going
to stay
now we need that skill set to perform at
a very high level to create the
credibility to make the ask and go to
your boss or whomever is creating or
maybe not even creating the problem but
who has the ability to help you create
the solution now you go and say i'm
performing at a high level yes yes oh my
god you're amazing okay cool here are
the things that i would need to change
so often people's first instinct is just
peace out and they don't realize that
there are many things that they could
have done
to restructure the role to create more
space for themselves in order to stay
but what people end up letting happen is
they let themselves burn out and then
they want to leave and go somewhere else
not realizing that they will have the
same problem at the next job
and instead of doing the work themselves
solving the internal problem of how we
ended up here whether it's lack of skill
set not setting boundaries whatever the
case may be
but keeping that ownership keeping that
responsibility recognizing that if you
make different choices you get different
outcomes so that you can go ahead and
change things there now again if you
want to leave leave by all means take
your skill set and go elsewhere but make
sure that you're not doing what i was
doing in my early 20s when i was about
to move to new york because i was
unhappy in la and i thought that la was
a problem in reality it was my mindset
once i changed my mindset suddenly i was
amazing
because it wasn't about la
it was about me and i thought ah like
something's got to change and so i just
wanted to go as far away as i could but
it wouldn't have solved the problem i
would have gotten to new york only to
have the same issue again and again and
again
i had to address my mindset and once i
did that then everything changed
so
be very careful be very thoughtful about
how you approach unwinding this problem
if you're always blaming other people
you're not going to get where you want
to go because you're not looking for the
things that you can do differently
your
letting your psychological immune system
take over
make it other people's problems
and then you're not able to
change
and once you realize that your life
is an exact reflection of your choices
now it's not so you feel bad it's so
that you remember if you make different
choices you get different outcomes and
so now you can make these changes or
gain more skills or whatever it is
that's needed to get the life that you
want now no matter where you go you will
feel completely comfortable that you can
shape things to your liking but you have
to know how the game works
you have to know that building skill set
is the key you have to know that
communicating with your boss what's
working what's not working and to have
earned the credibility to make the ask
do all that you'll have no problem your
brain has evolved to be a thing
and there's a lot rightly so
of focus in the
popular zeitgeist around mindset about
understanding the mind
and that is critically important but so
few people take the time to really
understand what gives birth to the mind
which is your biology
and so understanding
your
mind
within the context of evolution and the
brain
become critically important and people
that uh don't take the time to
distinguish between
the brain and the mind are doing
themselves a disservice i think much of
what they go through is going to be
it's going to be surprising is what i
was going to say but the reality is what
people end up getting stuck on is they
confuse feeling with thinking
and
the immediacy of feelings the visceral
nature of them
there's something about
embedded in the way that we experience
an emotion is this
just screaming from our subconscious
that this is real this is true this is
this is like this is it this is the
context everything you need to know dear
mind is contained in this emotion
and
it's really an interesting process that
i
i think warrants a lot more thought on
certainly my part
and probably science's part and for sure
any of you that are following along at
home
a big part of what you should be
thinking about
is the nuance of how all of this comes
into being and how
how emotions are
the great trick that they pull is they
they paint themselves to be self-evident
thank you for letting me think in real
time here
this is interesting
emotions feel self-evidently
right i don't even want to say true
because true doesn't capture
what's really going on when i try to
talk about the physics of being human
a big part of that is that
sense
that my reaction
to this moment to this event
does not strike me as a decision
it strikes me as self-evidently
right
because of the things that i feel
and
i'm pretty sure that as we went through
one of the classes i read
a quote by thomas soule which i'm going
to paraphrase
and it's
the problem isn't that timmy doesn't
know how to read the problem isn't even
that timmy doesn't know how to think the
problem is that timmy doesn't know what
thinking is he confuses it for feeling
and we feel something
it feels so self-evidently right
that this reaction that we're having is
not an echo of biology and context and
our own life experiences in a bazillion
decisions about what to believe that we
have made it feels self-evidently
the
only
logical
way to react to this set of
circumstances and that is what leads
people to spiral because people have
different reactions they both think they
are self-evidently right and people
spiral and so now re-anchoring you guys
back around this idea of no no you have
a goal
the only thing that matters is will
reacting the way that you're reacting
take you towards that goal and if we can
all embrace this idea of fulfillment
that fulfillment is the goal having a
positive emotional state that is
resilient to the ups and downs of life
because we have self-respect self-worth
we're elevating ourselves improving
ourselves and
elevating improving those around us
if that's our goal
and we can all buy into that
now we have a steering mechanism and
this is the thing that's crazy making
for me in this you know um cultural
upheaval that we're living through right
now
which is
people don't agree on what the goal is
and when you don't agree on what the
goal is now you have what lisa and i
call a collision of values when you have
a collision of values either talk about
the collision of values or shut up like
legitimately those are your two options
because option one
let's talk about the collision of values
and like what should be the goal
fruitful things can come out of that
arguing about the t as lisa and i called
the biggest argument we ever had was
over a cup of tea now you can imagine
that doesn't make any sense how could
you ever get in a fight that large over
a cup of tea the answer is you can't but
you can get in an argument that big
about a collision of values which then
attacks your sense of self identity
there's this incongruous thing where
your reaction feels self-evidently
correct
and yet this person is acting
in a crazy way because the way that i
feel
that is self-evidently
correct there's no need to even question
it it is obviously right
now
you get these massive fireworks because
the other person is thinking the exact
same thing
they feel self-evidently correct because
they have all these emotions that are
kicked up by their biology that is
kicked up by millions of years of
evolution misinterpreted through this
lens that we live in called life
in a modern context completely removed
from the evolutionary soup
that our brains marinated in
our brains
marinated in as they were formed
and now all of a sudden people cannot
allow themselves to conceive
that
oh this emotion was a choice
which i have made somewhere through a
string of the gazillion little moments
that led up to right now in this moment
all of those decisions have formed a set
of values
and those values are essentially
invisible to me because i have mistaken
them for truth therefore my values
become water right to the fish fish is
the last one to know what water is it's
just it permeates everything in their
world it just is it's like us in air
right that actually had to be discovered
imagine
the
hundreds of thousands of years like
really think about how long where you've
got human level cognition as we think of
it today
and yet there's no concept of
i'm in this thing
it just
you're here
and values become
that water
you don't even think about them you
don't think that they govern essentially
every aspect of your life
and yet they do
and the failure to recognize that my
values are
not objectively real they are simply
choices that i have made invisibly
based on all these emotions that i've
gotten which were kicked up to me by
evolution
i don't understand them i don't
understand what drives them but they
feel self-evidently true therefore i go
with them therefore however i feel i
confuse with thinking and i think i've
thought through the problem i think i
have articulated what my goal is and how
i'm going to get there but the reality
is i've just been feeling this whole
time
and
chaos ensues now let's play a game and
let's call this game
what would tom do
now i want you to ask do you think that
tom is going to stay in a bad job for
long
no
that's the i'll skip to the last page
and
tom has a bad job uh skips the last page
tom leaves the job
now
tom's going to be very thoughtful
because i completely understand that
this is largely about yo i have to pay
bills hey tom nice for you you don't
have kids and you've already been
successful so that's not really helpful
for me
now i will say that
joy and fulfillment are the punch line
of life not money not success not
adoration so you are losing losing
losing if you're staying in a job that
makes you unhappy i promise if you have
kids and that's the thing that's really
making this difficult you are bringing
that unhappiness home
and so
we have a moral obligation
to break that to make sure that we are
pursuing things that are joyful so that
we can show our kids hey this is how
it's done now
you're not stuck at a job there's
something that's making you feel stuck
at the job i'm going to assume for now
that it's money keeping a roof over your
loved one's heads that that to me seems
like the scariest so okay assuming that
it's at remember there are always two
levers lever number one make more money
level number two need less money
okay you can pull on either lever you
want
now if you say up tom i can't need less
money it's just we're all we've already
cut it all to the quick you know my kids
just need a certain amount it just is
what it is okay amazing so now we're
gonna make more money awesome how do we
go about doing that first of all let's
identify what we hate about our job
because there might be are there other
roles within that company if it's just
the job but not the company is there
somewhere that we could move in which
case we go ask hey i want this job which
pays more money what would i need to do
what skill set would i need to have what
expertise would i need to demonstrate in
order to get there
and then go do that thing
if it's the company and we just the
company's toxic we can't be there
anymore then i will ask
how many resumes have you sent out in
the last 48 hours if the answer isn't
250 then we've got some work to do
now let's assume that the answer is 250.
then we have to figure out why aren't we
getting a response do we not have a
skill set that's marketable is our
resume terrible are we not going out to
the right places have we not framed
ourselves well
could be any one of those things but we
have to be honest and real and figure
out what we need to do to get out of
this situation but we certainly don't
just accept defeat and go wow this sucks
this is my whole life
nights and weekends is also going to
come to our
help our aid here so nights and weekends
if you know whoa i just don't have the
skill set that i need to go find another
job then we're going to start building
that skill set
maybe the skill set is interviewing
getting good at interviewing and then
we're going to get good at that but we
are going to find a way out of our
situation and we are going to find a way
out of our situation quickly so do not
accept defeat hold yourself accountable
to the truth to what you need to do to
get out of that situation and then get
out
because as you said our time is truly
limited
the key here is recognizing that there
really is only one path to success and
that is you're going to have to set the
bar ridiculously high and then surpass
all expectations you want to really show
people that you are capable of doing
things that other people cannot when you
can outperform other people and i know
nobody likes to think this is a
competition but the reality is
when you can do things that other people
can't do
and if those things are valued by the
company you are going to move quickly
through that company even if your boss
is trying to steal your ideas which i
know is something that happens to a lot
of people
if you really are the person that's
coming up with the ideas
and your boss wouldn't be able to get
very far without them you've got
leverage
and so understanding that being able to
outperform people is always the right
answer that's where i would focus okay
then the next thing is so i've got this
amazing skill set then the next thing is
when i'm always going to be growing my
skill set day after day two i'm going to
take my job description and i'm going to
say all right this is the stuff that i
have to get done in the first half of my
day and do it extremely well and then in
the second half of my day i'm going to
go find other projects that the company
is trying to get accomplished see what i
can do to help help other people take on
responsibility for projects that are
beyond my job description and then i'm
going to do them just as well as i do my
actual main job
people that do that are worth their
weight in gold not only will you endear
yourself to the people that you're
helping but when you go to your boss and
say hey are there other projects that i
could take on maybe even things that are
outside of the exact department that
you're in that's going to be a huge help
almost every company is looking for
people that
show initiative and are able to be
trusted with additional projects and if
you're in a company where they just
aren't interested in that they don't
want people that show initiative which
by the way i challenge i think if you
put me into a company even with strict
hierarchies even with political intrigue
all that stuff that i would find a way
to be useful to other people that i
would find a way to help other people
oh there's a quote i'm gonna paraphrase
it go something like this it's amazing
what you can accomplish when you don't
care about the credit
so if you don't care about getting the
credit and you're just helping people
i think people are definitely going to
take that help now the key is that you
make yourself indispensable to them once
you're indispensable to them now you
have that leverage and so being able to
use that leverage to illustrate that you
have a long track record of high level
performance within the company now when
you go and start asking for a raise
you're going to be much more likely to
get it and here is the secret to getting
a raise go to your boss or whatever
department it is you're trying to move
into and ask them what would it look
like i want this title or i want to make
this much money what would i have to
deliver to you in order to get that and
if you get them to explain to you like
hey if you were able to do xyz thing
that would be no-brainer i would
definitely put you forward for that
promotion amazing now you know exactly
what you need to do now you just need to
go make sure that you get the skill set
that's going to allow you to do that
better than other people now my thing is
i'm always trying to reach beyond what
i'm getting paid to do because remember
i started out as an employee okay i've
not always owned my own companies so
when i was an employee that's what i was
thinking about like i want to be
indispensable i want to i want people
that fear of loss with me i want them to
be afraid that i'm going to leave
because i am delivering so much value
i'm not saying that's not my job
instead i'm saying what does a company
need and then i'm helping the company
get that thing and so when you're able
to assess what problems the company is
facing and help make those problems go
away you become extraordinarily valuable
when you're communicating very directly
about what you want and finding out what
you would need to do to get there and
then delivering against that you're
going to find yourself going up when
you're constantly helping other people
with their projects and delivering a
high level of quality and not asking for
the credit for that you're just doing it
because you want to help people
while i have no doubt some people will
take advantage of you the vast majority
of people will not and you will find
yourself meeting those people again and
again and people wanting to champion you
and lift you up
if you run that strategy i'm telling you
right now you will be able to make
things happen in your current company my
obsession is to get people to understand
that you are having a biological
experience now why do i want you to
understand that you're having a
biological experience because i want you
to understand that the brain reacts a
certain way
and you can actually insert yourself
into that and
change your approach
framing
the way that you react
and in changing those things you will
change not only the way you feel but the
outcomes that you're able to get and so
i want to introduce you to victor frankl
and cognitive behavioral therapy so
viktor frankl said between stimulus and
response is a gap
and
how we choose to react in that gap will
determine the rest of our lives now if
you don't know viktor frankl he wrote a
book called man's search for meaning
he wrote that book after getting
released from auschwitz okay this is a
guy that survived multiple concentration
camps and
he was a neuroscientist
and his ability to explain
what is happening inside the mind of a
human during something that catastrophic
is breathtaking and when you realize
that a guy that went through something
that just seems unimaginable for a human
being to
endure
says the way that you endure it is to
one find meaning in your suffering so
why am i going through all of this what
do i expect to see on the other side of
in your case
shortening the window okay this was a
big thing in my life
learning to emotionally soothe
whoever emotionally soothes themself the
fastest is going to win because you
don't waste the week spiraling out of
control right so if for me it takes
three seconds to emotionally soothe and
it takes you a week you can imagine how
much more progress i'm gonna make in a
year than you're going to make
okay so
viktor frankl says we've got that gap
for you that gap may be very very small
and now what we're trying to do is widen
that gap now how are we going to widen
that gap we're going to widen that gap
with cognitive behavioral therapy
cognitive behavioral therapy is beyond
the scope of this um video to go into
all the sort of details about it but i
will say one of the most important
things that's talked about in cbt is
pattern interrupting
so you know that these patterns aren't
serving you you know that spending a
week derailed not feeling resilient is a
waste of your time
so now when you feel
that
lack of resilience the emotional
distress you're going to interrupt that
pattern now i'll give you an example in
my own life so
for me i don't allow myself to feel
overwhelmed and as dumb as that sounds
it works
extraordinarily well so as i can feel
that you know that sense of like
like agitation like you can feel your
brain like speeding up and you can sort
of feel yourself like escalating and
moving towards panic
in that moment i say to first of all i
bring my chin down
and i furrow my eyebrows and i say i
don't do
overwhelm
and by saying that phrase it interrupts
the pattern
and the reason i know that works goes
back to this idea of you're having a
biological experience and i know
that there is nothing either good or bad
it is thinking that makes it so right
shout out to mr shakespeare there's
nothing either good or bad but thinking
makes it so it isn't what's happening to
you it's what you think about what's
happening to you so i'm not overwhelmed
because i don't do overwhelm and now all
of a sudden by reminding myself i don't
do overwhelm now i may take things off
my plate i may decide no matter what's
going on right now i'm going to sit and
meditate i may remind myself that
breathing from my diaphragm will
physiologically whether i wanted to or
not
if i do it long enough it will move me
out of the sympathetic nervous system or
flight into the parasympathetic nervous
system rest and digest that is
physiological and so i'm gonna do those
things now
that doesn't mean that i'm wired
differently than anybody or that i'm
doing anything you know particularly
special but it interrupts the pattern of
escalation that i've gotten into because
i'm thinking that this is bad i'm
thinking oh my god i've got all these
things going on i'm never going to be
able to handle them there's so much
pressure what am i going to do
and in that moment what i do is remind
myself i don't do overwhelm so for you
it may be reminding yourself i don't
spiral out of control for a week i don't
allow that in myself
what i do is i meditate what i do is i
remember failure as part of the process
what i do is remind myself that like
artificial intelligence i need these
samples i need these moments of failure
this is exactly why i need an
anti-fragile personality my very
identity is tied up in learning okay
that's a huge thing
when you tie your ego to being the
learner now all of a sudden the pattern
interrupt becomes i'm the learner
i don't mind that i failed nothing to
spiral out of control about i'm going to
learn from this and i'm going to keep
going in fact i want to know what can i
learn from this what's the lesson here
and when you change your framing and you
look at that and you take advantage of
viktor frankl's gap
and you fill that gap with i'm the
learner i'm going to get better from
this what can i learn
everything else is going to take care of
itself
we have to make sure that the anxiety
response atrophies so neurons that fire
together wire together and this is not
the surprising part i'll get to that in
a minute so neurons have fire together
wire together so the
anxiety
loop
has become easy for your brain to do
easier than anything else so you are
more likely to have this anxiety
response because you've just done it
like you said since you were a kid
so we have to get those connections to
atrophy and the way that we're going to
get those connections to atrophy is
actually going to start with our
diet
now i have found in my own experience
that because of the gut brain connection
the number one driver of the anxiety
impulse is caused by dysbiosis so you're
eating and or drinking things that are
causing the sense of unease which your
brain going back to the previous answer
your brain is going to justify the way
that it feels so you feel anxious and
you're like
what am i anxious about then your brain
is going to tell you a story oh you're
anxious about xyz
it's actually not true
you feel anxious because of what you ate
or drink
and then your brain is simply overlaying
a story onto that thing so
now let's exacerbate that a thousand
fold and say no no this thing really is
anxiety provoking yes but now it's a
question of amplitude
so what we want to do is bring the
amplitude way the hell down so we're
going to get our diet right in my own
life
seventy percent so not a hundred
but seventy percent of my anxiety was
caused by my diet and as i removed diet
monster and diet coke
and i miss them both dearly they are
lovely but they made me feel anxious
and as soon as i cut them out of my diet
my anxiety improved so dramatically that
it was startling
now of course like anything it takes you
know a couple weeks to really work its
way out of your system now that doesn't
mean that i went from not or having
anxiety to not having anxiety but i went
from these huge amplitudes of anxiety to
them dialing down 70
it was incredible it was the biggest win
in my journey of anxiety so removing
that was usually important getting sleep
also hugely important exercise hugely
important
and then meditation hugely important if
you are doing those four things
and then do one fifth item which we'll
call pattern interrupt so that every
time you begin to get on that loop you
interrupt yourself
you don't allow yourself to think about
that thing that triggers your anxiety
so we get the diet right get the
exercise get the sleep get the
meditation so we're getting better at
turning down the volume on the anxiety
amplitude
and then over time as you pattern
interrupt and stop yourself from even
thinking that and rehearsing the failure
and the worry and all of that now you're
going to find that those bonds of
anxiety in your brain the literal
connections are going to atrophy
and your brain doesn't at first it
doesn't leap to the same amplitude then
it doesn't leave to the same amplitude
as often and then it just doesn't leap
as
often and that's how you begin to undo
the anxiety
and then of course there's always
therapy so don't be afraid to see
somebody to help you through this
process if nothing else is working
undoing anxiety is extraordinarily
difficult i unfortunately know this
first hand
burnout is a tricky beast burnout has a
lot to do with the things that you
i won't just say love doing
but they have a lot to do with aligning
the things that you're doing with things
that give you more energy so whatever it
is that you're engaging with you want to
find a way
to
really engage with that in a meaningful
way and so there are a couple parts to
that so number one you want to make sure
that you understand the why that you're
doing this so that you can attach
meaning and purpose to it when you've
got meaning and purpose behind something
everything changes
getting good at life being good at your
job succeeding paying the bills all of
this stuff is so hard that if you don't
have a why that you're able to plug in
so i'm paying my bills so that i can
support my family all right that's an
incredible why but you really want to
think about that you want to focus on
that and then the other is just making
sure that you're able to engage with it
in a way that allows you to experience
progress so getting better at something
and moving forward in your life is one
of the foundational pillars of human
happiness and so making sure that you
are finding ways to engage with what
you're doing in such a way that it
allows you to be fed while you're doing
this instead of having the energy
stripped away okay that's part one part
two in all of this is making sure that
you understand
an idea that a lot of people myself
included who like to be ultra hardcore
have to really learn
and that is doing less is always an
option
okay doing less is always an option so
if you're starting to feel burned out
you need to pump the brakes and i always
tell myself i don't do overwhelm
now i don't say that because i can carry
an infinite weight i cannot i have my
limitations just like anybody else
but the reason that i don't burn out is
because as i feel myself getting close
to my limitations i don't tell myself
like come on like you can do anything
just keep going
now i am hardcore i'll be the first to
admit that i make sure that i'm leaving
it out on the field that i'm playing as
hard as i can
but i make the demand that even hard
work is done in a joyful manner so i am
at all times pursuing fulfillment in a
joyful manner it just so happens that
fulfillment by nature
is working really hard to gain a set of
skills that allow you to serve not only
yourself but other people okay working
really hard that's part of it that's
that's a directive inside of our brains
given to us by evolution so you have a
directive in your brain to work hard and
if you don't work hard there will be a
sense of dis ease in your life you won't
feel right something will feel like it's
missing you won't know what it is you'll
be grasping for something and it will
seem like it's going to be a thing you
need to get to attain whatever when in
reality
you need to work hard
that working hard there's a reason that
working out leaves you with this amazing
feeling nature had to incentivize that
you would work hard because going out
hunting foraging protecting your family
all of that stuff was brutally difficult
when you you know go back hundreds of
thousands of years
and that's what we came up through and
so nature only has two tools pleasure
and pain if you're doing the right
things pleasure if you're doing the
wrong things or not doing something you
should be doing like working hard then
walloped with pain you get
so
that's a key you want to be working hard
towards something that matters and
allows you to serve not only yourself
but other people
when you start doing that now all of a
sudden you're back in that energizing
mode you don't have to worry about
burning out but working hard is a key
part of this but when i get to the point
where it's like all right i'm i'm really
working hard but i'm now reaching a
limit where even with all the meaning
and purpose and all the joyful pursuit
of fulfillment i'm now reaching a point
where this isn't fun
you need to acknowledge that and back
off
that's not the time to keep pushing
right you needed to gut check yourself
you needed to make sure that you weren't
just being lazy but when you realize i'm
not being lazy this is just not fun
i'm now at a point of diminishing
returns need to be honest about that
acknowledge it trust yourself to have
busted your ass that you don't just grab
for the uh what was me you know i'm
exhausted it's like no man i've really
played hard i've really gone after this
i've made sure that there's meaning and
purpose i've made sure that i'm pursuing
fulfillment i've made sure that there's
progress in my life but now we've hit a
point it's not enjoyable
back off
relax
take a tuesday off meditate daily
find some way
to get calm
and creative
prioritize your sleep
make sure you're eating right and
exercising all of these things matter a
lot
when it comes to burnout
so
be very thoughtful
that
even something that you love that you
recognize there can be a point where you
just need space you need a minute you
need to take some down time and that you
actually allow yourself to take down
time but that you're checking yourself
to make sure you're not just being lazy
the one conversation that i don't want
to have with my wife is
hey you know we we had literally i think
just got in the house like six or eight
months before that
so i was like i do not want to have that
conversation and so that's where the the
mentality of burning the ships becomes
important but tie it to something that
is already real it's already there
there's no way around it you're not
going out of your way to create more
problems for yourself so i was not going
to lose that house and so that became
like the thing in my mind all right
we're going to try this but we are going
to make it work and so he literally got
a sawzall out and a blowtorch he cut
that apart he put it back together and
it actually worked
and that was one of those moments where
you're like whoa man you really do have
to have a certain appetite for risk and
so that's the third thing i'm going to
say you guys need to do you've got to
give your yourself permission to royally
because if you're afraid to royally
if you're afraid to lose the house it's
okay to say i'm not going to do it man
i'm going to fight and push and i'm
going to do everything i can to stop it
but if you're not willing to accept
those kinds of consequences you will
have to play it smaller
so you've got to give yourself
permission to royally now why am i not
afraid of royally
because i know one thing this is so
important
failure
is the single
most information-rich data stream that
exists
you will never learn faster from
anything than you'll learn from failure
one
pain psychic pain triggers all kinds of
things in your brain the hippocampus
becomes more active your amygdala
becomes more active you write the
memories harder your brain focuses on it
more so there's just this intensity that
happens when you fail
also failure is essentially
the closest thing you're going to get to
a sporting result the nice thing about
sports and part of the reason they
become like this gladiatorial thing that
we obsess over and think about is
because you know who won and you know
who lost you know who's the best you
know who's the worst you can see the
stats you watch it happen before your
eyes it's very hard in life we don't
often get that does my boss like me do
they not like me am i gonna get the
promotion am i doing what i want should
i even be in this job like you have no
idea and then you make a decision and
you don't know like would it have worked
out better the other way who knows you
never get to try it
so when life slaps you in the
mouth
and you realize that you've really made
a catastrophic error
then if you can approach it
defenselessly
meaning
you're not trying to protect your ego
because you wisely have already promised
yourself that you're not going to tie
your ego to the outcome you're going to
tie it to the sincere pursuit so you
need only ask yourself one question in
attempting that thing that i just failed
catastrophically was i sincerely
pursuing the right outcome and if the
answer was yes you get to feel good
about yourself
and so you step into that moment saying
i tried and i failed i know that failure
is the most information data rich stream
that there is
so
what is the lesson here
and getting good at teasing that out
and
facing even more than i'll say figuring
it out
facing
what you've done wrong
owning it
accepting it
allows you to not make that mistake the
next time
and my encouragement to you guys is
never judge yourself to the lens of a
moment you're going to mess up you're
going to mess up a lot
and if you loop negatively over that
mistake it just isn't effective
and i always tell people do and believe
that which moves you towards your goals
like if you just repeat that one
obsessively in your head then one day
you're going to get to a point where you
do something and really makes you
dislike yourself if you went back to
your 20 year old self knowing everything
you know now what would you tell
yourself to have a fulfilling career
i would tell myself
to only do things that matter to me
in the beginning i didn't have a why
and i lost almost a decade of my life
pursuing something without a y and i
will just tell you that it's utterly
miserable
and once i finally said i'm never
pursuing anything ever again that
doesn't have a strong why then my life
got a whole lot better as a human as a
social creature i'm telling you right
now it is very easy to wake up
to fight
to go to war
for people that you love and care about
and to build something that's going to
help them that you can do but when
you're showing up just trying to make
money you're not going to make it it is
a brutal slog and no amount of money in
the world can ever touch how you feel
about yourself and i'm telling you the
reason that i harp on fulfillment all
the time is the formula for fulfillment
is very simple you're going to work very
hard
to gain a set of skills
that matter to you
that are exciting to you
in service of a goal that's exciting and
honorable
and by honorable i mean that it serves
not only you but other people
now if you're doing all of that
now you're going to have that energy
that you need to keep going to keep
fighting to keep pursuing it if you
don't have that it really becomes
miserable and since at the end of the
day the only thing that matters is
joyful fulfillment i wish that i could
have spared myself that decade so i
would very much
focus myself on that idea i was so
hardcore about wanting to get rich so
that i could go
build the thing that i wanted to build
but i didn't even know why i wanted to
build a film studio
i just knew i loved film
that was it
but even that
would have been way too hard
to do without a reason why i wanted to
do it
so creating is amazing but i know plenty
of people that are in the film industry
that don't control their own destiny
that are extraordinarily frustrated so
even this thing that they love so much
there's so many other people that are
involved with it that even that can be a
very difficult path so you better have a
really compelling reason why you want to
tell those stories because if you have
that reason when things are hard and
you're asking yourself why the hell am i
doing this what is the point
that you have an extraordinary answer
and if you have not yet read the book
man's search for meaning by victor
frankl
read it in fact don't even finish this
video
go read man's search for meaning by
viktor frankl it is
extraordinarily important i
go to my now father-in-law to ask for
his blessing to marry his daughter
and he says no
and i was like
whoa okay well at least you're being
honest and uh i had said look i know you
see as this young broke
undereducated kid but i promise one day
i'm gonna make your daughter a wealthy
woman
and
he was like very kind very kind my
father-in-law has always been
extraordinarily kind to me but he was
nonetheless honest about that he didn't
see how i was going to take care of his
daughter and he even asked me directly
he said look
i have become very successful my
father-in-law and
i have given
lisa a certain lifestyle
and how do you plan to take care of her
and
i was like
so full of that youthful like no you
don't understand like i'm gonna become
something
and then i had to reconcile
that idea
because she ended up saying yes
and then i found myself laying in bed
four to five hours a day every day and i
didn't have a job and i was living in my
soon-to-be mother-in-law's house and my
wife well girlfriend at the time fiance
uh was working and my one job was to
make a sandwich for her when she came
home at lunch and there were times where
i was scrambling out of bed
to have that sandwich made before she
walked in the door and i was just like
this is gnarly how are you ever gonna
make her wealthy if you're laying in bed
all day you barely get out of bed fast
enough to make her a sandwich at her
lunch break so she's already been at
work for hours and hours and hours
gotten up gotten dressed ready driven to
work gone worked for hours come back
home to see you you're scrambling out of
bed your hair is a mess you're wearing
the same thing every day
and not like in a steve jobs way in a
like i'm too lazy to
get close way so you look like a bum
not doing your hair
i was a total mess
and
i'm just like how do i reconcile
that i actually believe one day i'm
gonna make her a wealthy woman but i'm
not getting out of bed
and that was when i realized there's a
difference between ambition being a
dreamer
and having drive and seeing those dreams
to fruition
and so i set a rule for myself because i
felt ashamed
and for the first time in my life i
didn't try to hide from the shame but it
was in this period that i started to
think of my then fiance soon-to-be wife
as a witness to my crimes
and i remember thinking
when i was alone i didn't feel that kind
of pressure to succeed i wanted to
succeed but i didn't feel
pressure because if i didn't nobody
suffered but me nobody lived in the
unfurnished apartment but me nobody had
to sleep on the air mattress but me
but
now my wife to be
was
going to be affected by whether i laid
in bed all day or not and that filled me
with shame and it filled me with shame
in a way that i didn't want to hide from
i felt like it was right to be ashamed
of my behavior not to think i was
worthless but to to say i need to earn
my worth
and so i set a rule which is that i was
going to get out of bed in 10 minutes or
less so from the time i realized i was
awake until my feet were on the floor
and i was out of bed was never going to
be more than 10 minutes
and in many ways that's become one of my
most important rules i live by it to
this day
some 20 years later
that i get out of bed in 10 minutes or
less doesn't matter no matter what's
going on i'm out of bed in 10 minutes or
less
and
that
one step
got me to start working and it got me up
and saying okay what are my dreams
what's the obstacle that stands between
where i'm at where i'm trying to get to
what can i do in the next 15 minutes
that will move me closer to my goal and
i started doing those things and it just
became this routine this habit to
get up and get moving and
i never would have gotten there had i
said something like who does my
father-in-law think he is to say that
money doesn't matter
you know he doesn't know what we're
about or what we want to do
and
instead i said
either
stop saying that you're going to
achieve greatness and recognize what you
want to do is lay in bed
tell your fiance that's the truth of who
you want to be and where you want to go
which by the way is absolutely fine
but don't say you're going to do one
thing and then actually do another
there's no integrity in that
and that hurt and i didn't like the way
that felt to recognize that i was saying
something but it was just rhetoric
wasn't actually living up to it
and then it felt so good so good so
unbelievably good
to
do exactly what i said i was going to do
and
on a very long timeline it finally made
my wife a wealthy woman so i actually
did get this incredible moment which
will remain one of the greatest moments
of my life i'm sure forever
when jesus
13 years later
my father-in-law came to visit
this is when i was at quest and there's
300 000 square feet
a thousand employees walking around
protein bars coming off the line at like
1.5 million bars a day
and i said andreas
do you remember asking me how i was
going to take care of your daughter he
said yes
and i said how am i doing
and
he just started to cry and it was so
awesome like i said he'd always been so
kind and once we he knew that we were
going to get married whether uh he
wanted us to or not he never did
anything but support us but to have that
moment
for myself for him for lisa for it to
all have been
the result
of a simple rule
to get out
within 10 minutes
and start doing whatever my goals demand
and that was all it took a little bit of
shame
acted on
greatness is the most demanding mistress
you're ever going to encounter and i
understand the advice that i'm about to
give you is not
for everyone most people should turn
this off
but if you're going to stick with me if
you're going to listen to what i have to
say it's because you want something
tremendous in your life you want to
stand out from everyone else you want to
do something more than other people
think is possible you literally want to
stand outside the norm and if
that's the case for you
then understand that as albert einstein
said only one who devotes himself to a
cause with his whole
strength and soul
can be a true master
for this reason
mastery demands all of a person
if you want to
get great if you really want to make a
skill set your own if you want to be
able to do something and at the end of
the day if you want to transform the
world if you want to make grand changes
if you want to do all of that
all the empty words that people spout
all the time
let me tell you
the only thing that's going to separate
you from all the other blowhards we're
just talking words and will never do
anything
is to give yourself over completely to
let that obsession let that thing that
you love completely consume you and in
that
your only chance to really become great
lies
the only thing you have to believe in
lean close
hear my words
the only thing you have to believe in
right now is that
humans
are capable
of learning
that humans for whatever reason nature
has chosen to not endow us with a whole
bunch of like pre-programmed things so
for instance a baby horse a foal i
believe is how you say that
when they're born they can already walk
literally boom they come out and they're
walking and all as well because that's
all hardwired into them but a horse is a
horse is a horse and they're going to
stay a horse and that's that and you're
never going to find a horse reading
chaucer uh just not going to happen so
that's
all those decisions are pre-wired
humans on the other hand come out they
cannot take care of themselves they're a
lump of flesh
they basically know how to suckle and
that's sort of the extent of it
but now humans have the ability to go in
all these crazy different directions and
they can learn to become an
astrophysicist they can learn to become
a carpenter a doctor an astronaut like
the number of directions that humans can
go in is crazy the amount of what was
once known as junk dna we now know is
epigenetic signaling the way that we can
respond in all these different
directions to our environment to the
things we choose to focus our energies
on is is truly unique to humans is just
absolutely astonishing
so
understanding that that's baked into the
human animal is the ability to learn and
go in any direction so once you realize
that humans are adaptation machines that
we can learn anything now it's like okay
whatever you want to do
you can do it as long as you're willing
to pay that price i'm not saying that
it's not going to be hard it is going to
be very very hard i'm just saying that
it is doable and that you will receive a
return on investment in your energies
and that's what people need to know and
believe to the core of their being that
my time in this direction will be
rewarded now here's where people
themselves up there is this [ __ ]
debate about whether or not it is
hey am i pre-programmed i'm good at math
and so that's it and i should go do
things that are math or i'm good at
verbal and i should go do things that
are verbal i'm naturally gifted as an
athlete so i should go be an athlete
look i'm not saying people don't get
early wins people get early wins and if
you happen to love the thing you're
getting early wins and that's awesome
man and you'll find it just a little bit
easier you've got a headwind or a
tailwind i guess a tailwind you have a
tailwind um and so that yeah love that
but if they're the thing that gives you
the most energy in life
is something that you have no natural
inclinations for then go learn that when
i say
that i have zero
zero natural ability as an entrepreneur
i mean zero
i had to learn everything from not being
lazy to problem solving to overcoming my
paralyzing fear to look at world like a
puzzle dealing with anxiety
literally it it was comical as i was
going down my journey in the beginning
as an entrepreneur
to
figure this
out
it's ridiculous and then i meet people
who are like ripping flowers out of
people's front yards and selling them
back to them like when i say that that
was not me i had a paper route and i was
so chicken to go up to people's doors
that i actually only got half the money
that i could have gotten for the same
paper route the same amount of effort
but because i was so afraid to go knock
on people's doors and ask to collect the
money that was due that for like two
years i did a paper out for half the
money okay that's how
[ __ ] of an entrepreneur i was when i
started so
you can learn this stuff now my goals
demanded that i learn entrepreneurship
so i learned it so that's what i want
people to understand what is your goal
work backwards from there if it lines up
with what you're naturally good at
that's amazing and congratulations but
there are going to be times where it
doesn't line up and you've just got to
either change your goal or recognize
that i'm going to have to figure these
things out and because i'm an adaptation
machine as a human being i can do all of
that any advice for somebody who is
taking steps to make a positive change
but he is getting all kinds of negative
consequences for bad decisions he took
in the past at some point in fact i'll
just quote lao tzu the guy that wrote
the dao de jing
he said if you worry about whether other
people think about you you will always
be their prisoner so
unless you're prepared to be other
people's prisoners at some point if
they're hurling dirt on you if they're
constantly trying to re-bury you under
the earth that you're trying to claw
your way out from
then
you're never going to get out you've got
to just stop worrying about what they
think so they can't actually affect you
they can only try to influence your
mindset
so
and
even
even now
if people hate you slings and arrows you
could get a job digitally you could go
be a freelancer or an upwork or whatever
people don't even have to know who you
are so truly in today's world
they are not going to be able to stop
you from getting a job but they can
really mess with your head but only if
you let them so i will say
to that do not let them you've got to
understand who you're trying to become
believe in your ability to get there to
become that person to understand that to
continue to beat yourself up for
something in the past is not going to
serve you and so for that very reason
let it go and this is somewhere that i
think a lot of people get lost is they
don't spend any effort making sure that
the thing that they're doing with their
life is actually something that
generates excitement it builds
excitement it gives to them more than it
takes now it doesn't mean i'm not
exhausted at the end of my days i am
really tired but
i am having a
ball i'm having a ball it's fun i
believe in what i'm doing i'm excited
by what i'm doing and so that's where
you should be spending the vast majority
of your times but that's all stuff about
striving to do more to be more i'm
excited to acquire the skills i'm
excited to push myself it isn't a dark
and dingy place like i'm legitimately
amped up to do it and that's what i want
people to understand like
i'm
the amount of hours that i work the
hardcore way that i'm driven
the
overwhelming majority of that energy
comes from a place of excitement it
comes from a place of being enthusiastic
about what i'm doing there is 20 it's
the dark side i leverage it it is a real
thing for me and it helps me in those
acute moments when for whatever reason
the excitement just isn't enough at that
moment then i will think about the
people who wish me ill then i will think
about the things that are dragging me
down then i will focus on the
inadequacies in my life and that i
demand that i get better at those things
100
but it's an 80 20 split you've got to
learn to balance that split you've got
to put something that you give about at
the center of your life that is so so so
important andrew kirby youtube do you
believe in self-punishment and if yes
why i believe in this ferociously this
is advanced class and i know that most
people are going to have a seizure when
they hear me say this
but
if you don't learn
how to effectively not destructively
because that's where most people go they
get into an endless loop of
self-punishment which is totally
ineffective
but if you don't learn to punish
yourself you will never get where you
want to go now
that needs to pale in comparison to the
amount of time that you reward yourself
now you need to earn that reward if
you're just lavishing yourself with
emotional praise
and you haven't done anything then i
think that that will cheapen it will
ultimately mean nothing and quite
frankly i don't think you can really
bamboozle yourself i don't think if you
try to praise yourself for stupid i
think some part of you knows you haven't
done anything to deserve that praise but
when you set a bar and you meet that or
exceed that to then tell yourself hey
you did it you said you were going to do
it you did it and that is worthy of
praise and getting good at praising
yourself is incredibly
important and i think that most people
have a very hard time doing both most
people don't know how to effectively
praise themselves they don't know how to
get themselves first of all to do things
that are praiseworthy and then when they
do they don't take the time to
emotionally reward themselves meaning
you actually have to feel it it can't
just be intellectual
you've got to actually feel
that
and the same with punishment if you say
you're going to do something even if
nobody's watching
and you don't do it then you need to
emotionally punish yourself none of you
will ever know
whether i actually get out of bed in 10
minutes or less or not but i say i do
all the time
but every time i miss it even if i miss
it by seconds i just gave myself the
chills
even if i miss it by seconds
i will punish myself for that
because i said i was going to do it and
i didn't do it so the fact that nobody's
watching is utterly irrelevant to me it
has everything to do with myself now the
reason that this is important the reason
that i think that people need to do this
is because that's how you shape your
behavior so like water over time can
create create the grand canyon or you
can take
a polishing rock and shape
stones you can shape your personality
you can certainly shape your identity
and shape your behaviors if you learn
how to reward and punish yourself i know
a lot of people don't want to hear that
that is the truth of the human condition
what are some action steps i can take
right away to train my mind to not go
after easy pleasures and happiness and
instead seek the gratification that
comes from fulfillment
the great news is all you have to do is
recognize the truth of the human
condition
and the truth of the human condition is
that chasing momentary happiness
won't
fulfill you that's literally what i
wanted to say and
i'm not because we're talking about
fulfillment i won't use a just recursive
loop but that really is true all of that
stuff is so transient what makes
fulfillment interesting is that it is
this far more
stabilizing
neurochemical state so your brain is
constantly checking in with you
making sure on a subconscious level that
you're doing the things you need to do
to be of service to the group to be of
service to yourself to make sure that
you're taking care of yourself and your
family and your loved ones and your
tribe okay so there's this
subconscious
record keeping going on and that's
exactly what's happening that's why you
sometimes will feel the unease in your
body before consciously you know what's
going on
and you feel it ah there's something off
you need to take the time to identify
what it is to be able to articulate it
in a single nice crispy sentence so you
can figure out exactly what it is that
you need to do to move forward okay now
once you understand that that is just
the nature of the game that going after
these momentary things will be exactly
that
it's going to be momentary it's going to
fade you're going to have a sense of
unease you're not going to be in the
shape that you want emotionally once i
know oh going down that road is not
going to leave me in the emotional state
that i want to be in then it's very easy
to go well this one might be a little
bit more difficult it might take more
sustained effort but it yields these
tremendous results so the example that i
always give is
eating junk food
i love junk food and truly love it by
the way it is it gives me a drug-like
high it is so fun to eat sugary foods
the problem is that especially as i get
older it hurts
literally after the fact my joints will
hurt
i won't sleep as well i wake up the next
day and it's just like i have like a
slight hangover that's literally what it
feels like
and
because i know that that's the outcome
it's like well on the times where i
don't mind and it's like well i'm gonna
you know enjoy this drug-like thing for
a minute i'll sort of walk a fine line
have some fun here suffer a little
tomorrow but on balance maybe i come out
a little bit ahead on the happiness but
if i try to do it two days in a row
forget it three days in a row it really
starts to be like a real problem so even
over the holidays now
when i let myself off of you know the
hook with all of my normal disciplines
and all of that
even then now i keep myself in check
just because i don't like the way that
it feels so once you understand oh i can
do this thing over here and feel really
good or i can do this thing over here
it's very momentary it's very transient
it doesn't last i kind of you know i'm
not where i want to be and i begin to
ask myself questions like what am i
doing with my life so just knowing that
to me fulfillment is
much longer in duration it's much more
resilient i can be fulfilled even when
things are hard even when things aren't
going my way even when it's difficult in
fact the fulfillment i get from
contributing to the group is the very
thing that inoculates me from the hard
times being able to knock me all the way
down because on those moments where
you're just beleaguered
and you're getting it from all sides and
it just seems like everything is
crashing on you at once
in those moments you're going to cling
to what you're doing to help other
people
and nature will ensure that that is
going to make you feel way way better
you've got to instill in your mind that
the average human
is capable of
unbelievable improvement
that's that's the thing that's my
superpower i don't think i'm special i
just realized in looking at the science
that humans actually are capable of this
incredible amount of change it is the
strategy that our species took to be
able to
pass knowledge on through culture rather
than having to have everything be
instincts and in having that layer where
we can drink in the culture and read
books and learn from other people and
you know even now we're all learning
from things that people thought
thousands of years ago and wrote down
like it's insane it travels through to
you and all of that wisdom stored in
culture so that as your parents are
teaching you things they're actually
encapsulating a ton of the wisdom that
is endured whether it's endured from
religion or books or whatever like
you're
bathed
in a culture that is giving you all of
this incredible information and so
recognizing how powerful and potent that
is is
incredibly meaningful but you have to
understand that you have to allow
yourself to believe
that you can learn from that culture in
the same way that everybody else can and
that's what you're designed to do now
for me that completely
gave me the confidence and i put
confidence in air quotes because it's
not like i believe something specific
about myself i just believed that the
human animal is capable of this
extraordinary change and so now i just
needed to point myself in that direction
now once this is the key
once i realized that i could get better
at anything
it dawned on me that how i spend my time
is a spiritual consideration
and i didn't want to die with potential
that i failed to turn into skill set
that to me that speaks to me
how much of my potential can i actually
turn into skill set and get good at this
stuff and push and grow and improve like
that to me is just this incredibly
intoxicating loop
so
for me the discipline the confidence all
of that comes from recognizing human the
human animal nothing special about me
the human animal is capable of
extraordinary change i'm going to have
to put time and energy into doing it
but i'm capable of getting this change
therefore
i can do anything i set my mind to
therefore it really matters what i
choose to spend my time on therefore i
want to put structure and discipline in
my life so that i can move forward on
things that excite me that matter to me
because i really can't have this big
crazy dream that i'm thinking of so my
discipline is really born of my desire
to have that thing coupled with my
belief that i can actually get there
desire
and belief
get those two things right and the
discipline will take care of itself a
big thing that you can do in terms of
figuring out how to take control of your
path and steer yourself towards your
goals is getting really good at goal
setting
making sure that you
use the process of building desire to
figure out
how to increase your desire for
something
because steering yourself towards your
goals is really about wanting something
so badly that you're willing to try over
and over and over again in order to make
progress because the reality is as
winston churchill said success is the
ability to go from failure to failure to
failure without a loss of enthusiasm
now that requires that you really want
something
that you're able to read yourself to
know if you want that thing badly enough
that you're going to stick with it
because if you don't one of two things
is true thing number one either you have
chosen the wrong thing but a lot of
people
use that excuse over and over and over
as angela duckworth says in her book
grit if you find yourself doing that
three times or more odds are you have a
grip problem you have a tenacity problem
you're not sticking with it you're not
pushing through the boredom and the pain
which are inevitable if you want to get
good enough to be extraordinary at
something so we need to set these goals
that meet two criteria they are exciting
to you
you want them very badly
you've invested time and energy into
wanting that thing it needs to be based
on something real it's very hard to turn
an ember into a raging inferno when
there was no real ember there to begin
with so it needs to be something that is
legitimately interesting to you and then
you're going to fan those flames and
really build emotional importance and
emotional resonance around this thing
then the second part of any goal it
should be honorable meaning that
pursuing it is
going to allow you to serve not only
yourself but other people
now the great news is that because we
are a social creature the more that you
do that the more that you're pursuing
something that allows you to elevate
yourself yes but other people most
importantly
now mother nature has just put a reward
into your brain when you do that i
promise you will feel better i promise
it is just the way that we're wired when
you serve other people you will feel
better
serve other people and you will feel
better now that doesn't mean that you
have to be mother teresa and that you
can't be doing things for yourself again
the goal should be exciting and
honorable but once you're doing
something that you really care about and
you are acquiring a set of skills that
matter to you that you just want to get
good at
but they are very much on purpose
allowing you to help other people
now all of a sudden you get in this
feedback loop of the more you engage the
harder you work the more skill set you
get
this really becomes a passion because a
part of passion in fact i don't believe
something becomes a passion unless it's
reciprocated by the people that you
serve and so when you're doing something
that really allows you to light other
people on fire and look that could be
building toy models in your house but if
nobody ever gets to enjoy those toy
models the odds of that really becoming
this self-reinforcing behavior are very
slim we all want to create something
that we share with somebody else and it
gets appreciated by them it brings a
smile to their face and it could be that
simple maybe what you create just makes
other people happy but in doing that
you connect to other people
you're elevating other people you're
engaging you're being a social creature
you're contributing to the group and in
contributing to the group now it can
become a passion because you're getting
the feedback that you need to go back
and do all the boring painful stuff that
true
mastery requires
and if you want to achieve your goals
mastery and desire
are going to be the two most critical
components next to clarity
i think all of us have a desire to be
looked at favorably especially by the
people that we care about that we
respect but you have to like victor
frankl said understand that there is a
gap between stimulus and response
and in that gap you have the ability to
choose something as a way of reacting
that isn't your
emotions dictating that so you're gonna
have an emotional reaction when you do
something people disapprove almost
certainly certainly happens for me
you're going to feel that sting of like
oh that sucks i really wanted people to
be behind me i really want people to
cheer i really want people to clap for
me that's amazing but at the end of the
day you've got to be able to say what is
my goal and what reaction to this
stimulus actually moves me towards my
goal and that needs to be the thing that
overrides everything else so step one is
having that clear goal knowing what
you're trying to accomplish and then
step two is the ability to assess
whether or not your emotion that which
is the subconscious speaking to your
conscious mind so if you think of
emotions as the subconscious which
processes data in a faster and vaster as
they say fashion meaning it can process
a whole lot of information that your
conscious mind would not be able to
process through rapidly and it can do it
much more quickly so it coughs up
instead of speaking in the language of
that little voice you actually hear
articulating words in your head it's
coughing up an emotion so it's all of
that experience all of the
things that our brain does to make sure
that we protect ourselves that we don't
get ostracized by the group which makes
sense in a evolutionary context but not
so much in a modern context that's why
the subconscious is speaking in emotion
but you can take that emotion and say
hey this doesn't make sense for my goal
feeling badly about myself worrying
about what other people think about me
it's only going to slow me down it's
only going to hold me back i need to be
able to trust my instincts which i have
trained and now move towards what
my goals demand and so when you're able
to do that when you're able to read the
emotion check to see if there's a lesson
to be learned but if there's
in wallowing in that emotion if it's
going to move you away from your goals
then you set that to the side and
practicing that and getting good at that
and filtering everything to your goal is
how ultimately you're not going to
spend a lot of time caring about what
other people think and so the savior for
me has been the belief
and the part of my identity which says i
only do and believe that which moves me
towards my goals so obsessing over
negative thoughts about what other
people think doesn't and so i just let
it go and move on and it literally comes
down to what you allow yourself to think
about so just stop yourself using
cognitive behavioral therapy techniques
stop yourself from thinking about what
other people think now here's how you
develop a passion it starts as a minor
area of interest you gain areas of
interest by encountering a lot of stuff
so if you have countered a lot of things
in your life go out there and encounter
stuff go sailing go
take a dance class go study neuroscience
like whatever it is
just encounter a whole bunch of very
broad diverse things from that you're
going to get sparks of interest like oh
i actually found that interesting i want
to learn more dive deep through
engagement not through pondering through
engagement you're going to realize
whether something is
going to turn into an area of
fascination so as you go deeper into it
you're going to either become fascinated
or you're not if you're not fascinated
move on if you are fascinated then
that's an area where you're going to ask
yourself one very simple question do i
want to become the best in the world at
that thing if you do if you want to
become truly extraordinary in that thing
then go down the path of gaining mastery
now the reason i think that it's wise to
ask that question going in is when you
frame it of i'm going to become the best
in the world at this immediately people
understand the amount of time energy and
weight that it would take to become
truly great at that thing and i don't
think that passion can happen unless
you're becoming truly great at that
thing that's part of passion
i don't think people are deeply
passionate about something that they
really suck at and i'll give you an
example i love video games i absolutely
love playing first person shooters i
learn a lot from them i get a lot out of
them i really just intrinsically enjoy
the time it has both that sense of
eating a cake because it's just fun in
the moment and
it i
pull from it life lessons business
lessons i practice getting out of the
sympathetic nervous system into the
parasympathetic nervous system it's
literally gamified so i'm getting better
i have points i can
you know have my improvement turned into
metrics it's all of it i really really
enjoy but i won't say that i'm deeply
passionate about it cause i'm just not
that good at it so it's one of those
things if i really wanted to develop a
deep passion for video video games and
put it at the center of my life that
then i would set down that path of
really practicing now this is like this
is the most important thing that passion
will do for you which is it's going to
pull you through boredom it's going to
pull you through the hard times and
that's why it's really got to be
something that you just are prepared to
become great at because when you're
prepared to become great there's just
these insane moments of boredom
repetition and all of that and if you
have this burgeoning passion coming out
of that that's what's going to give you
the energy to get through it so it's
this symbiotic relationship between a
developing passion and how hard it is to
actually really get great at something
so the things you get great at need to
be something that is this developing
passion so there you have it that's how
you do it and that's why you do it what
is the best way to truly experience
gratitude when you have a goal-oriented
mindset
well i'll give you just like raw tactics
so first of all
i do this as a part of my meditation
routine
i try to experience gratitude both and
like the big things and in the small
things they're not always tied to
my goal
it is purely something to get the
neurochemistry pumping
in the right direction to be in a good
head space to really feel and
internalize on a visceral emotional
level
that sense of like real deep fulfillment
gratitude appreciation for what you have
going on in your life so like i said
i'll pick something big and i'll pick
something small so
it might be something like you know i'm
so grateful for 17 years with my wife
somebody that really understands me that
knows my pettinesses knows my like
the dark ugly corners of my mind like
they know all of that and they still
love me and they they're with me on this
journey and you know she picks me up and
brushes me off when i'm down i mean it's
just like beautiful i'm literally
slipping into the mindset right now like
i am so grateful for that moment and by
the way that's how easily it happens
like you start and this is exactly what
i'm going through in my head these are
the exact words that i'm thinking in my
mind i don't say them out loud but i'm
thinking them in my mind which then
creates this neurochemical cascade and
you find yourself actually experiencing
the emotions of that gratitude then i
will pick something small let's say
take my dog bonsai
man when he gets a haircut there's some
his fur feels like velvet there it is i
love pet that dog just don't know when
his hair is freshly cut
super small super stupid but i'm
actually grateful for it and it's
amazing
um so i might think of something small
like that i might think of like whoa
on a warm day like that cool breeze is
just amazing or air conditioning
air conditioning is amazing let's all
take a second to just be appreciative of
air conditioning that again literally as
i'm talking about this i'm actually
feeling the gratitude for these things i
have found in the absolute worst times
of my life
meditation can get me back to zero every
single time meaning i have absolutely no
physiological remnants of stress or
anxiety it is so amazing and so powerful
that i only wish that i'd started doing
it years earlier and it was mark devine
the navy seal that i was talking about
before
that helped me realize because i thought
of it as very um weak and effeminate
which growing up feeling like a weak
effeminate kid
getting tough and getting stronger has
been a huge part of my journey so i
didn't want to do anything that i felt
was moving me backwards now he was one
that slapped me around and was like look
it just makes sense it's getting you out
of that sympathetic and into the
parasympathetic and so i thought well if
it's good enough for a navy seal then
it's good enough for me i tried it and
it was life
changing and there have been times in my
life since i started meditating i
honestly don't know how i would have
made it through
if i didn't have meditation because that
ability to get back to equilibrium to
zero with what i call no background
radiation um
it's so powerful so
meditation has become a huge way for me
to to manage anxiety which is really
really powerful so there it is and i
will do one quick cycle so you can see
how deadly simple it is i normally sit
cross-legged so take that for what it's
worth but i'll do it just normally
seated now
i do it with my eyes closed and i
breathe in through my nose out through
my mouth and it looks like this
hey there it is all right nice and easy
um i did the second part of the cycle so
you can see how long that i usually end
up holding that exhale hold again i just
do it until it's not pleasurable anymore
i don't feel like i'm holding my breath
it literally just feels like an exhale
and it's so weird even in that short
cycle i almost forgot i was doing an ama
uh that's how powerful meditation has
become for me i i get lost so rapidly if
i'd had this is the last thing i do when
i meditate i put headphones on
over-the-ear headphones
and i listen to the calm app i do not do
guided meditation some people love it i
absolutely hate it
and i listen to the sounds of nature and
i find that insanely powerful and if i
had had my headphones on i do fear that
i actually would have forgotten i was
doing this uh but that's how quickly you
can with practice and i've been doing it
now for
about three years um with practice you
can get into a super chill state
never
give up
on what you really want to do
the person with big dreams is more
powerful than the person with all the
facts h jackson brown
truer words have never been spoken it is
one of the most interesting things about
the human condition
that all of the facts in the world no
matter how true something may
objectively really be the only thing
that matters is whether or not you've
got the energy to see through to the end
of what you want to do and the energy
comes not from truth
the energy comes from your dream the
energy comes from what it is that you
want to do
the energy ultimately is born out of
what you want to create it's born out of
a willingness
to allow yourself to dream it's born out
of a willingness to think that you
actually can do it it's born out of a
willingness to take that first step but
the only reason that you're going to
take that first step is you believe that
you can actually make your dreams come
true and that sense of this thing that
you have in your mind that you can make
it real that you can bring it into the
real world and have that excitement that
you've long fantasized about and
understand and really feel in your gut
that that thing that you've dreamed
about can be real and when you have that
that's when you're going to have the
energy that you need to push
and to fight and to go through all of
the difficult things that you're going
to have to to get on the other side and
make that dream real
as ferdinand fox said
the most powerful weapon on earth is the
human soul on fire
but the human soul can't be on fire
without a dream a human soul is not fed
by facts a human soul is fed instead by
a belief that it can accomplish what it
wants to accomplish it's fed by that
thing that idea that you've had in your
mind that you fanned those flames of
interest and turned it into a real
fascination and fanned those flames
further into excitement and allowed
yourself to truly embody
that belief
that you can make it happen
so right now whatever it is whatever
crazy dream you have and we all have one
stop judging yourself for it stop
telling yourself that you can't do it
and understand when you cultivate that
fire when you take that little ember and
you fan it into a raging inferno that
that
thing that human stole on fire is what's
going to allow you to build something
that the world has never seen before
but it starts with that dream it starts
with your willingness to cultivate that
to think about it to allow yourself to
do that because so many people stop
themselves they think they're inadequate
they think that they could never do it
and even if that is a fact
it's not something that's going to help
you live a life that excites you it's
not something that's going to help you
excite other people
the one thing that will do that
is the dream
so right now allow yourself that
simply to dream
where should one look to find something
to get passionate about is this an
introspective journey or something more
extrinsic okay so it is actually oddly
enough
step one is not introspective step one
is get out play get lost have fun try a
lot of things challenge every assumption
that you have get out of your age
bracket hang out with people way outside
of how you grew up a totally different
circle you will be utterly shocked
utterly shocked by what ends up being of
interest to you again you're not going
to stumble on some grand passion but
you're going to stumble on something
that's interesting to you wow never
never even knew this existed and yet i
find myself interested and i want to go
down that path but the only way to do
that is to get outside this freakishly
small bubble that you have this is why a
lot of people and i say that because all
of us live in a freakishly small bubble
and this is a reason that people often
tout travel as a way to
um really shake up their assumptions
about the world things they didn't
realize were assumptions to go and see
the way other people live and realize
whoa like they seem like they're having
an amazing time and yet they do things
so dramatically different than the way
that i was raised for instance so
getting out and even if you can't leave
your house the internet the internet man
the internet will introduce you to the
most eclectic
eclectic people on the planet
so if you can't afford to travel
get a device with an internet connection
and just start searching random follow
random stuff and see where it leads like
guys
enrich your lives
go down these weird rabbit holes when a
friend invites you to do something super
weird say yes go try it that's how
you're gonna find this stuff but it
isn't it isn't turning inward and i'm a
huge believer and i spend way more than
80 of my time inward reflecting inward
but that isn't the first
step the first step is encountering
then you can reflect what do you
recommend for a person who isn't
fulfilled in their position to make sure
they don't get caught in a loop of
negativity while searching for something
else so to me this all comes down to
what you're rewarding yourself for what
you value in your life so i value action
so if i knew that i had gotten myself
into a bad situation and i have
something in my eye
if i knew that i'd gotten myself into a
bad situation and rather than sit there
and beat myself up over it i would say
okay you're in a bad situation you got
yourself here nobody would blame you
and now instead of beating myself up
over the fact that i got myself into
that situation i am simply going to say
only action matters and so now i'm just
going to start taking action to make
sure that i'm fixing that woe and i find
because i so value action and by the way
i value it because i know where it leads
it leads to my desired outcome it leads
to learning worst case so taking that
action driving myself forward pushing
myself that is what i'm going to reward
myself emotionally for so immediately i
get this sense of relief from anxiety
from stress from worry because first i'm
i'm
acknowledging how important that is in
my life because it yields rewards and
then second you're really going to get
engrossed in it and you're going to just
be lost in the details of actually
trying to solve that problem by
leveraging your action to get the
desired outcome so those two things i
think will serve you very very well as
you go down that process so just make
sure that you
really have that emotional buy-in to the
importance of action when does
confidence become harmful how do you
detect overconfidence that might stop
you from striving to get better every
day okay so
i
i don't think that confidence is ever
dangerous what i think is dangerous is a
way of approaching the world if you
value yourself for being a master if
your confidence comes from i know this
stuff then you're going to be in trouble
because i think that the reality is that
being a master
feeling like you're an expert that stuff
is a trap and you need to keep your
beliefs nimble so the more you learn the
more you need to be checking yourself to
make sure that that stuff isn't
calcifying into dogma meaning that it
becomes like i do it this way and that's
the way i do it that's the way i've
always done it that's what my success is
based on so i'm going to keep doing it
that becomes incredibly dangerous
especially now in a world that changes
and evolves so quickly what worked
yesterday may not keep working tomorrow
so you've got to constantly be willing
to check your assumptions and i think
the easiest way to check your
assumptions is to write them down
writing them down is going to force you
to have clarity on what your assumptions
are so that's really really important
and i'm going through this right now and
building the studio
i have a belief system about the way
that things work i have a belief system
about the way that marketing works and
i'm constantly trying to check that and
so i found that there were some beliefs
that were so embedded in me i didn't
even realize anymore that they were
beliefs and so there's that whole
concept of david foster wallace the guy
that wrote the speech this is water look
it up on youtube
right now in fact i don't even mind if
you bail out of this right now to go
watch it it's that important to get this
concept burned into your psyche
the fish
is the last one to become aware of the
water
it is so ubiquitous that they don't even
realize it's a thing
that's what happens with your beliefs
you begin to believe them and
internalize them so much that you forget
at one point that that was something
that you learned or discovered or chose
to believe
and so at some point that now may be
holding you back so i find writing them
down so that i'm aware of what my
assumptions are i'm aware of what my
beliefs are then i can go in and say and
this is straight from tim ferriss if you
haven't watched the episode of impact
theory with tim ferriss check it out he
talks about what if you did the opposite
what if he did the opposite for 24 or 48
hours it's very easy to overcome that
and back out of it if it doesn't work
but for 24 or 48 hours just try it what
if you had the opposite belief what if
you approach things in the opposite
manner would you get a better result and
doing that and checking your
beliefs and assumptions against that can
be incredibly powerful it would
certainly open up new vistas new
possible avenues i highly highly
recommend that hey tom i'm curious how
you determine what your top tasks are
for any given day this is a great
question already i have many different
to-do items and it's hard to know what
to prioritize okay so you've got to know
what's my goal where am i trying to get
to you're going to back into
the daily tasks okay so now if we know
what we're looking at our daily tasks
that are meant to feed into some longer
term goal what we're looking for are
lead dominoes so what are the things
like if i do this then it will have a
knock-on effect so i'll give you an
example one lead domino for me is always
to delegate so i'm always starting my
day by thinking what can i delegate
because once i delegate something then
it starts moving on so on my list of
important things one of the sections is
to delegate so
doing that that is um it's a time
multiplier it's a force multiplier so if
i get that going then now all of a
sudden that project is running and it's
essentially like i've just added man
hours to my day so i'm going to start
with those things i'm going to make sure
that everybody's moving and doing the
things that they want the next thing is
what is a roadblock an impediment to
something that's important in my world
generating revenue or building the
community those are the two things that
like i really think about so if i do
this thing will it generate revenue or
will it
make the community bigger so those are
the two things that we have to do now
ultimately the reason i give i care
deeply about revenue is revenue is the
juice man it is the engine that is going
to allow whatever you're doing to go on
so making sure that you're thinking
about things that are actually going to
generate revenue for you and then for us
the community is those are the people
that we want to serve they also give us
a lot of power so thinking about them
but ultimately we won't be able to serve
them for very long if we're not able to
get the revenue coming in that we want
and even if we have revenue coming in
and we're profitable every bit more
revenue that we get because we're
filtering it back into the company then
we're just able to serve more and more
people so i'm always looking at those
two things also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
so here is the reality about money so
the reason that people chase it even
though i know you've heard a thousand
times and it is absolutely true
money can't buy happiness
that if you're chasing money the odds of
you ending up with some level of
dissatisfaction is incredibly high but
the reason that people ignore that and
the reason that they keep chasing it the
reason that i myself
live the cliche of money can't buy
happiness is because money actually does
have power now the thing that money lets
you do the thing that gives it that
power the reason that people will chase
forever and ever and ever is it is the
great facilitator now being the great
facilitator does not mean that it gives
you the thing that you secretly want in
your life so here's the punch line about
happiness
the goal of all of this the goal of this
game of life that we're all playing
it is not money it is not success it is
entirely brain chemistry it's entirely
how you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself it's about being deeply
fulfilled it's about being proud of who
you are now those are all for me
synonyms it's the same thing which i'm
just going to shorthand to fulfillment
the thing you're chasing is fulfillment
it's the only thing that doesn't sway
with the wind so
happiness in its typical definition is
very transient so i want to shift people
over to thinking about fulfillment
fulfillment is often born of suffering
it's born of not doing something you
want to do it's born of doing the hard
things
being proud of yourself comes from that
being proud of yourself comes from
working your ass off to acquire a set of
skills that by the way in and of
themselves in acquiring it you found
that pleasurable it's something that
you're interested in you've hopefully
crafted
developed built
a deep passion around
and in acquiring those skills in service
of that thing that you love and enjoy
you're able to serve other people
that's it that's the truth of happiness
that's the truth of the thing that is
going to give you that sense of
fulfillment that's going to allow you to
enjoy your life money is never
ever ever in and of itself going to do
that money
buys cool
money is
able to give you those temporary
dopamine rushes of going and shopping
for something and getting it and then
it's cool but then that coolness factor
wears off very rapidly
the flip side of that using that money
to build something that you believe in
that not only empowers you but helps
empower other people that will help you
develop long lasting fulfillment
so that's the real thing but if you're
doing something that isn't making you a
lot of money but you're passionate about
it you enjoy the day today and it's
allowing you to build skills that serve
you and other people i promise you if
you had to choose between the two which
by the way you don't but if you had to
choose between the two always and
forever every single time
choose fulfillment this question is from
froso marinu on youtube when your home
life is less than desirable it's not
where you want to be living but you're
trying to break out
how do you not let the chaos around you
affect your vision and drive so this is
a framing question so what you want to
do and this this tony robbins asked this
question i think it's absolutely
brilliant
how is
the worst thing that ever happened to me
the best thing that ever happened to me
so in your circumstance how is being in
a chaotic home life the best thing ever
now i'll give you one example off the
top my head and this is exactly why i
play first person shooters can you learn
to stay calm in the chaos
because my friend i have the chills
if you can do that
it will serve you so well in every
single area of your life in a
relationship in business if you want to
be an athlete if you want to play games
like
whatever it is that you do one of the
things that you're going to have to
become great at is letting all of the
noise drift away into nothing and
getting into laser focus on the thing
that you're working on now when i give
advice like that to people they think
well how do i practice the amazing news
is the best thing that has ever happened
to you is that you have a built-in way
to do that your home life is mass chaos
so now you get a chance to practice i
have the chills you get a chance to
practice every day
tuning out the chaos and getting laser
focused on something
that's framing now there are other ways
but that one is so powerful that i'll i
will end it there focus on that it is
practice practice every day thank god
you're living in this chaotic
environment man congratulations i am
literally willing to do whatever it
takes within my code of ethics to
achieve my goals so that's what i mean
by break myself in half i'm willing to
work literally monday through friday
if i'm awake i'm either working or
working out so
to the point where i brush with my i
brush my teeth with my headphones on so
that i can get the last little eeks of
the day out from the moment i wake up i
go immediately to the gym i work out and
then i immediately do my morning routine
which i've gone through so many times
and won't waste my time with it now but
i
go right into that immediately and that
carries me all the way through so like
today um i woke up at what 4 15 so i
wake up around that time every day
somewhere between let's say three and
five that's my typical wake-up window
and i'm going to work or work out from
that moment until i go to bed and i go
to bed at the same time every night
which is 9 p.m so somewhere around about
8 45 is when i begin my nighttime ritual
brushing my teeth and all of that but
even then i am listening to a book or
something along those lines so
that is what i mean by break myself in
half and then on the weekends by the way
on a lazy weekend i probably work five
to seven hours a day and then on a
hardcore weekend like last weekend where
i was working literally until midnight
on a saturday um i'll clock
say 13 14 hours of work that's on a
weekend so that's what i mean by break
myself in half now
the whole point is
that i'm building something that i
believe in i'm building something that
gives me a deep sense of fulfillment i
believe that not only am i empowering
myself and making myself stronger and
more capable of the things that i want
to do and the things that give me joy
and give me more energy than they take
but that i am doing something that
serves a lot of people that goes way
beyond me and
the not-so-secret thing i love the
puzzle of seeing if i can figure out
something that other people can't figure
out that is a deeply enjoyable pastime
of trying to
improve myself to learn enough to think
of the problem in a new enough way to
challenge my own assumptions to do all
of that to be able to see a problem in a
way that nobody else can to see a
solution that nobody else can see i love
doing that so all of this energy and
effort it is
in things that give me more energy than
they take so it's just a pleasurable
existence and i don't want to hear
people
i don't want people to hear in what i
say that i'm just like grinding it out i
tried that i did that for six and a half
years and it was a total misery so i'm
not saying that i'm saying work that
hard in service of something that you
believe in that makes you feel alive
that you love doing
if you do that then breaking yourself in
half
that just becomes a metaphor for the
amount of energy that you're willing to
put into the things that you believe in
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome do you see
my recent sit down with tom bill you
check the interview right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there people
make bad decisions because they need to
protect their ego and they get put in a
situation where the only way to protect
their ego is to hide or be defensive or
whatever if you invest like that
then you're good and it doesn't matter
pretend i'm on my deathbed